एवन एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू
ऑल सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है आई एम
लाउड एंड क्लियर
गुड इवनिंग प्रणय गुड
इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
यशराज टेक
थििस्ट सीरीज बंद मत करिए सर यार एटलीस्ट
लाइव क्लास में आप 60 मेरे को ले आइ हर
बार 60 मिनिमम रखिए है तो आई विल आई विल
नॉट स्टॉप द
सीरीज मुझे जो चाहिए आपको वो भी तो देने
की आपकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है
ना अब इतना तो आप लोग कर सकते
हो सलमान वेरी गुड
इवनिंग कम सिंह
शर्मा वेरी गुड इवनिंग
थोड़ा सा वेट करते
हैं 5 मिनट का इसलिए थोड़ा पहले स्टार्ट
किया मैंने क्लास ने
एटलीस्ट जो हमें चाहिए उतने तो स्टूडेंट
होने
चाहिए ट इज वाई अगर यह आप जो एफर्ट नहीं
कर सकते उनके लिए वेरी हेल्पफुल सीरीज है
तो आप इसको और स्प्रेड कीजिए और उनको
बोलिए ना कि लाइव
आइए इससे क्या है कि मेरा डाउन ग्रेडेशन
हो रहा
है खुश हुआ वेरी गुड इवनिंग अभी भी देखिए
30 स्टूडेंट ही है
नहीं देवेंद्र ऐसा नहीं है कि आप फ्री
फोकट में लाइ लाइक कमेंट करते रहेंगे तो
उससे ठीक है यू को तो एक मोट ट पर आपको
ठीक है कि उसकी रीच आउट मिलता है
बट यह तो मेरे लिए डी मोटिवेशन
है नहीं फिर वही है ना कि मेरे पास बच
जाता कि मैं इस कोर्स को पेड कोर्स बना
दूं कोस्ट डिलीवरी करने के
लिए और सॉरी थोड़ा सा ज्यादा डिले हो गया
अबकी बार क्लास में क्योंकि मैं कहीं पर
बिजी था मुझे टाइम नहीं मिल पा रहा था तो
आई विल ट्राई कि अभी अल्टरनेट डे प मैं
आपकी इस क्लासेस लेकर आऊ ताकि जो कुछ
क्लासेस डिले हुई है उनको हम रिकवर कर
पाएंगे तो मोस्ट प्रोबेबली आई विल ट्राई
कि एक दिन छोड़ के एक दिन मैं आपकी क्लास
लू लाइक जो सेशन होते हैं नॉर्मल क्लासेस
के ऐसे ही मैं ट्राई करूंगा कि आपके सेशन
लेने की अगर कोई इशू होगा तो आपको मैं फिर
भी मैसेज ग्रुप में आपको व चैनल जो है
वहां पर आपको मैसेज मिल जाएगा कि 100 100
डेज तक आई एम नॉट फ्री तो उसके बाद ही
क्लास लूंगा तो मैं थोड़ा सा ज्यादा बिजी
था तो इसलिए आपके क्लास नहीं ले पाया बट
अभी मैं थोड़ा फ्री हूं तो आई विल ट्राई
की हर अल्टरनेटिव में आपकी क्लास ले पाऊं
चाहे क्लास आपकी वन एंड हाफ आवर की बजाय
आपकी वन आवर्स की हो चाहे टॉपिक दो की
बजाय एक ही कवर हो तो लेकिन वह हम कवर
करने की कोशिश
करेंगे हाय गुड इवनिंग प्रेम
हाय प्रियंका हाय एंड हर
थय यस स्टार्ट करते हैं ओनली 36 एटलीस्ट
40 50 तो होने
दीजिए आई एम
फाइन उसको सॉल्व करना है तो ठीक है अभी हम
अपने कोर्स को फिनिश करेंगे फिर एक काम
करते हैं साथ में ही लाइव क्लासेस में के
बार कोर्स फिनिश करते हैं क्योंकि कोर्स
में आपको ट्रिक्स टूल्स टेक्निक्स और बहुत
सारी चीजें आपको सिखा दी जाएंगी आपके पास
एक अप्रोच होगी उसके बाद साथ में हम क्या
करेंगे कि
कुछ चैलेंज टाइप चलाएंगे कि
हम कुछ सीटीएफ चैलेंज चलाए कि इतने हम अब
टारगेट रखेंगे अभी इतने सॉल्व करेंगे देन
उसके बाद फिर हम
और चैलेंज चलाएंगे कि ओके अब इतने सॉल्व
करेंगे तो जिससे क्या होगा कि आपकी सीटीएफ
की प्रैक्टिस हो जाएगी और लैब्स भी सॉल्व
हो जाएंगी तो मे भी आपको वक थ्रो टाइप
मिले या आपको एक उसी अप्रोच में मिले जिस
अप्रोच में कोर्स डिलीवर किया गया उसी
अप्रोच में आपको चैलेंज सॉल्व करने में
हेल्प मिले तो अभी कोर्स फिनिश करते हैं
और कोर्स फिनिश करने के बाद ट्राई करते
हैं कि हम सीटीएफ पर भी काम करें ओके
सीटीएफ प अभी भी काम करेंगे कोर्स में
जल्द ही अभी अपकमिंग कुछ 8 टू 10 क्लास
में हम स्टार्ट कर देंगे सीटीएफ पे बट
ज्यादा सीटीएफ पे प्रैक्टिस करने के लिए
तो हम वो भी ट्राई करेंगे
ओके यह जो ग्रुप में जो यह फालतू की जो
बकवास करते हो यार प्लीज स्पैमिंग ना
फैलाए ग्रुप में
कोई नहीं मोहम्मद इसमें आपको उससे ज्यादा
सीखने को
मिलेगा आपके पास फंडामेंटल नॉलेज होगी बट
कुछ ऐसी चीजें जो आपको इसमें सीखने को
मिलेंगी जो उसमें नहीं
होंगी ओके क्लास शुरू करते हैं अभी हम तो
आज की जो क्लास है आपकी मेटा स्लेट
फ्रेमवर्क के बारे में है और आज की लास्ट
क्लास है मेटा स्लेट के ऊपर और उसके बाद
बीच में जैसे ही हम कोर्स को पढ़ते रहेंगे
और चैलेंज सॉल्व करेंगे तो हम मेटा एक्सट
के थ्रू भी ऑटोमेटिक करेंगे ओके तो यह था
अभी स्टार्ट करते हैं
चलो लास्ट क्लास जा पढ़ने से पहले मैं
आपको बताता हूं जो आपका डाउट बोर्ड है
डाउट बोर्ड पर अभी भी किसी का कोई सवाल
नहीं है तो इसका मतलब क्या है कि आपके
डाउट क्लियर है ल है तो मैं चाहता हूं कि
इस डाउट बोर्ड पर ज्यादा से ज्यादा आपके
सवाल मिले ताकि लोगों को हेल्प मिले
नाउ नेक्स्ट लास्ट क्लास में मैंने आपको
मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क के बारे में
इंट्रोडक्शन दिया था कि मेटा स्लेट
फ्रेमवर्क होता क्या है ओके और देन उसके
बाद मैंने आपको बताया था कि हम पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग में ऑटोमेशन का क्यों यूज करते
हैं इसका भी कारण बताया था मैंने और देन
हमने डिस्कस किया था कि ये एक मॉड्यूलर
फ्रेमवर्क है मॉड्यूलर का मतलब क्या होता
है यह भी मैंने बताया था एंड हमने डिस्कस
किया था कुछ हिस्ट्री कि यह 2003 में
डेवलप किया गया था ओरिजनली परन लैंग्वेज
में था 2007 में तो इसकी थोड़ी बहुत जो
बेसिक हिस्ट्री थी हमने वह कवर की थी
लास्ट क्लास के
अंदर नेक्स्ट हमने पढ़ा था कि मेटा
स्प्लिट जो फ्रेमवर्क है उसके तीन एडिशंस
है मेटा स्प्लिट प्रो मेटा स्प्लिट
एक्सप्रेस मेटा स्लेट फ्रेमवर्क और जो
कम्युनिटी वर्जन है जो आपका यह फ्री है
ओपन सोर्स है जिसको हम यूज करने वाले
हमारी क्लासेस के अंदर नेक्स्ट मैंने आपको
बताया था कुछ टर्मिनोलॉजी जिनके बारे में
आपको पता होना चाहिए कि इंटरफेस मॉड्यूल
वलने बिलिटी एक्सप्लोइट पेलोड लिनर यह
सारी चीजें जो बार-बार हम यूज करेंगे
क्लासेस के अंदर तो आप फम आपको पता होगा
कि ओके इस टर्मिनोलॉजी का यह मतलब है सर
इसलिए यूज कर रहे हैं यह आपको पता होना
चाहिए था जो हम लास्ट क्लास में डिस्कस कर
चुके हैं और इस चीज को मैंने क्या
एग्जांपल के थ्रू आपको समझाया था नेक्स्ट
मैंने बताया था कि मेटा पलेट फ्रेमवर्क के
कुछ इंटरफेस होते हैं तो बेसिकली मैंने
बताया था कि मेटा पलेट फ्रेमवर्क कंसोल जो
एक इंटरफेस है वह क्या है मेटा स्लेट
फ्रेमवर्क सीएल आई क्या होता है लेकिन
2015 में इसको डिस्कंटीन्यू कर दिया गया
था और इसकी जो सारी फंक्शन हम मेटा स्प्ले
एमएसएफ कंसोल के अंदर देख सकते हैं जिसको
हम यूज कर सकते हैं उसके बाद मैंने आपको
बताया था मेटा स्प्लिट कम्युनिटी एडिशन भी
अवेलेबल होता जो ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस
होता है उसके बाद आर्मी टेक यह भी एक जावा
बेस्ड ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटर फेस फ्रंट एंड
मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क है जो क्या करता
है आपके मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क का यूज
करता है बिहाइंड में आपको इंफॉर्मेशन
प्रोवाइड करने के लिए तो उसके बाद वहां तक
हमने लास्ट क्लास में डिस्कस किया था तो
लास्ट क्लास से रिलेटेड किसी का कोई डाउट
है तो प्लीज बता दीजिए
कोई भी कोई डाउट नहीं
है ओके
चलो फिर अब हम बात करते हैं मेटा स्प्ड
एमएसएफ मॉड्यूस के बारे में क्या होता है
तो जो एमएसएफ मॉड्यूस है उसके अंदर
डिफरेंट डिफरेंट टाइप्स के मॉड्यूस हैं तो
उनके बारे में जानते हैं तो सबसे पहले जो
मॉड्यूल है उसके अंदर जो है एक्सप्लोइट
मॉड्यूल इसका मतलब क्या होता है इट इज यूज
टू टेक एडवांटेज ऑफ वलने बटी एंड इट इज
टिपिकली पेयर्ड विद ए पेलोड बेसिकली क्या
होता है जो एक्सप्लोइट मॉड्यूल है वो
वल्नरेबल की एडवांटेज लेता है मतलब वलने
बिलिटी का फायदा उठाता है और इसको क्या
किया जाता है पेलोड के साथ पेयर किया जाता
है बेसिकली जो एक्सप्लोइट है उसके अंदर
पेलोड भी होता है क्योंकि जो आपका
एक्सप्लोइट है व वनटी की फायदा उठाएगा
उसके बाद क्या करेगा आपको कनेक्शन
प्रोवाइड करता है अब पेलोड क्या होता है
पेलोड इज ए पीस ऑफ कोड दैट इज डिलीवर्ड
बाय द मेटा स्लेट फ्रेमवर्क टू टारगेट
सिस्टम एंड इज देन एग्जीक्यूटेड ऑन द
टारगेट सिस्टम आफ्टर सक्सेसफुल
एक्सप्लोइटेशन ओके एंड इट्स वेरी
इंपोर्टेंट टू अंडरस्टैंड दैट एन
एक्सप्लोइट मॉड्यूल इज पेयर्ड विद ए पेलोड
एंड पेलोड इज यूज टू टेक द एडवांटेज ऑफ
वनटी एंड पेलोड इज ए मिशिस कोड दैट इज यूज
टू एग्जीक्यूट कमांड्स और गेट रिवर्स सेल
फ्रॉम द टारगेट सिस्टम बेसिकली कहने का
मतलब यह है कि जो आपका एक्सप्लोइट है
एक्सप्लोइट हमेशा पेलोड के साथ पेयर किया
जाता है पेलोड एक पीस ऑफ कोड बोल सकते हैं
एक मलेशियन कोड है जो आपको क्या करता है
रिवर्स सेल या आपको एक सेल प्रोवाइड करता
है जिसके थ्रू आप क्या करते हो टारगेट के
ऊपर पर अपनी कमांड एग्जीक्यूट करवाते हो
या अपने टास्क परफॉर्म करने की कोशिश करते
हो आफ्टर गेनिंग एक्सेस अभी इनकोडर क्या
होता है इट इज यूज टू इनकोड पेलोड्स इन
ऑर्डर टू अवॉइड एंटीवायरस डिटेक्शन अब
एंटीवायरस से से बचाने के लिए या जो
सिक्योरिटी सोलूशंस है उनसे बचाने के लिए
उसको डिटेक्ट डिटेक्ट होने से बचाने के
लिए हम क्या करते हैं अपने पेलोड को इनकोड
कर देते हैं फॉर एग्जांपल विंडोज टारगेट
हैव विंडोज डिफेंडर इफ वी डोंट इनकोड आवर
पेलोड इट मे बी डिटेक्टेड एंड वी विल नॉट
गेट अवर रिवर्स कनेक्शन बैक इट इज ट्रू
अभी क्या है कि अगर वहां पर फायरवॉल है तो
फायर वाल को बायपास करने के लिए हम क्या
करते हैं अपने पेलोड को इनकोड करते हैं सो
दैट कि हम उसको सक्सेसफुली बायपास कर पाए
और उससे कनेक्शन रिवर्स बैक ले पाए अदर
वाइज क्या होगा कि वो आपकी फायर वाल उसको
डिटेक्ट कर लेगी और ब्लॉक कर देगी और आप
वेट कर रहे होगे मुझे रिवर्स कनेक्शन
मिलेगा टारगेट से लेकिन आपको कभी मिलेगा
नहीं और आपको क्या लगेगा कि ओके ये
वल्नरेबल नहीं है बट एक्चुअल क्या होगा
उसके वलने बिलिटी होगी लेकिन एक फायर वल
होगी जो उसको क्या कर लेगी प्रोटेक्ट कर
लेगी अ एक ऑक्जिलियम
दैट इज यूज टू परफॉर्म एडिशनल फंक्शन लाइक
पोर्ट स्कैनिंग एंड एमेशन अब पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग जैसे इम एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग है जो एन्यूमरेशन पार्ट है तो हम
किसके थ्रू कर सकते हैं ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल के
थ्रू कर सकते हैं किसके अंदर मेटा स्लोट
के अंदर नोप्स होता है यूज यूज टू इंश्योर
दैट पेलोड साइज आर कंसिस्टेंट एंड इंश्योर
द स्टेबिलिटी ऑफ ए पेलोड व्हेन
एग्जीक्यूटेड
ये कुछ अ मेटा स्प्लिट मॉड्यूस होते हैं
जो आपको देखने को मिलेंगे मेटा स्प्लिट के
अंदर नाउ उसके बाद पेलोड्स के बारे में
जानते हैं दिस इज वेरी इंपोर्टेंट टू
अंडरस्टैंड दे आर रिस्पांसिबल फॉर गिविंग
अस आइ दर रिमोट एक्सेस टू द टारगेट सिस्टम
और अलांग अस टू एग्जीक्यूट कमांड्स ऑन ए
टारगेट सिस्टम आफ्टर एक्सप्लोइटेशन जब आप
एक बार क्या करते हो सक्सेसफुली किसी भी
वल्नरेबल का एडवांटेज ले लोगे या वल्नरेबल
का फायदा उठा लोगे देन उसके बाद क्या करते
हो आप एक्सेस लेते हो एक्सेस गेन करते हो
किसी भी टारगेट सिस्टम के अंदर रिमोट या
तो रिवर्स कनेक्शन आपको मिलेगा या आप क्या
करोगे किसी भी कमांड या पेलोड के थ्रू
उसके ऊपर कमांड एग्जीक्यूट करोगे तो यही
काम किसका होता है पेलोड का काम होता है
तो एमएसएफ प्रोवाइड्स यू टू टाइप्स ऑफ
पेलोड्स दैट कैन बी पेयर्ड विद एन
एक्सप्लोइट जो एक्सप्लोइट के साथ जो पेयर
किए जाते हैं वो दो टाइप्स के पेलोड हो
सकते है एक तो नॉन स्टेज पेलोड हो सकता है
दूसरा स्टेज पेलोड हो सकता
है टाइप ऑफ पेलोड दैट यू विल यूज विल
डिपेंड ऑन द टारगेट सिस्टम एंड टारगेट
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर एज वेल एज यवर
रिक्वायरमेंट बेसिकली किस टाइप का पेलोड
आप यूज करोगे वो डिपेंड करता है कि टारगेट
किस टाइप का है या उस टारगेट की जो
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर वो किस टाइप की
है या आपकी रिक्वायरमेंट क्या है उसके ऊपर
डिपेंड करता है कि आप स्टेज पेलोड यूज
करोगे या नॉन स्टेज पेलोड यूज करने वाले
हो अब ये नॉन स्टेज पेलोड क्या होता है ए
पेलोड दैट इज सेंड टू द टारगेट सिस्टम एज
ए वल अलोंग विद द एक्सप्लोइट मतलब
एक्सप्लोइट के साथ वो क्या है कि एक साथ
ही भेजा जाता है आपका नॉन स्टेज पलट बेसिक
इसका साइज आपके जो एक्सप्लोइट का साइज वो
क्या है काफी बड़ा हो जाता है देन स्टेज
पेलोड क्या होता है स्टेज पेलोड इज सेंड
टू द टारगेट सिस्टम इन टू पार्ट्स अभी जो
स्टेट पेलोड होता है वो टारगेट सिस्टम के
पास दो हिस्सों में भेजा जाता है द फर्स्ट
पार्ट स्टेज जिसको हम क्या बोलते हैं
स्टेज कंटेंस ए पेलोड दैट इज यूज्ड टू
एस्टेब्लिश ए रिवर्स कनेक्शन बैक टू द
ट्रैक्टर कि जो स्टेज और होता है जो
फर्स्ट पार्ट होता है वह क्या करता है
अटैकर्स और टारगेट सिस्टम के बीच में एक
कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश करता है रिवर्स
कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश करता है देन उसके बाद
डाउनलोड द सेकंड पार्ट ऑफ द पेलोड दैट इज
नोन एज स्टेज उसके बाद जो सेकंड पार्ट
होता है पेलोड का जिसको हम स्टेज बोलते
हैं उसको डाउनलोड किया जाता है अब इनके
बीच में हम डिफरेंस समझते हैं तो डिफरेंस
क्या होता है स्टेजेस आर टिपिकली यूज टू
एस्टेब्लिश ए स्टेबल कम्युनिकेशन ब
कम्युनिकेशन चैनल बिटवीन द अटैकर एंड द
टारगेट सिस्टम बेसिकली जो अटैकर्स है जो
टारगेट सिस्टम उनके बीच में एक स्टेबल
कम्युनिकेशन चैनल एस्टेब्लिश करने का काम
क्या है स्टेज का है उसके बाद जो उसके बाद
आफ्टर व्हिच स्टेज पेलोड इज डाउनलोडेड एंड
एग्जीक्यूटेड ऑन द टारगेट स्टेजेज आर
पेलोड कंपोनेंट दैट आर डाउनलोड बाय स्टेज
बेसिक ओके तो यह कहानी थी आपकी स्टेज
पेलोड की बेसिकली क्या है कि एक्सपोटल में
कंप्लीट पेलोड को भेज देना बेसिकली मतलब
उसको पार्ट बिना पार्ट में डिवाइड किए
उसको बोलते हैं हम नॉन स्टेज पेलोड स्टेज
पेलोड में क्या होगा कि उ उसको दो पार्ट
में डिवाइड कर दिया जाए एक तो स्टेज जो
पहले कनेक्शन एब्लिश करेगा उसके बाद क्या
करें हम पेलोड जिसको हम स्टेज बोलते हैं
वह उसके ऊपर अपलोड कर दिया जाएगा
एग्जीक्यूट कर दिया
जाएगा यह मैंने आपको बताया पेलोड क्या एक
मिशिस कोड होता है एक्सप्लो भी मैंने
बताया था आपको अगर आपको याद है कि लास्ट
क्लास में मैंने ओके लास्ट क्लास में ये
रहा देखो ये इससे पहले मैंने आपको क्या
बताया था यहां पर कि एक्सप्लोइट क्या होता
एक मॉड्यूल है दैट इज यूज टू टेक एडवांटेज
ऑफ ए वनबिल वि विदन ए सिस्टम सर्विस एंड
एप्लीकेशन अभी एक्सप्लोर तो एक मॉड्यूल
होगा कोड है सेंट्रलाइज ठीक है लेकिन यह
जो एक्सप्लोइट है वो हमेशा काम करता है
किसके पेलोड के साथ पेलोड एक्चुअल में वो
पीस ऑफ कोड है जो टारगेट के पास डिलीवर
किया जाता है एक्सप्लोइट मॉड्यूल के
द्वारा दिस इज द डिफरेंस बिटवीन
एक्सप्लोइट एंड पेलोड
नाउ कंटिन्यू करते हैं यह आपको समझ में आ
गया होगा अभी बात करते हैं दे मोस्ट
पॉपुलर मेटा स्ड फ्रेमवर्क पेलोड दैट इज
नोन एज मीटर प्रेटर पेलोड द मीटर प्रेटर
पेलोड इज एन एडवांस मल्टी फंक्शन पेलोड
दैट इज एग्जीक्यूटेड इन मेमोरी ऑन द
टारगेट सिस्टम मेकिंग इट डिफिकल्ट टू
डिटेक्ट द टारगेट सिस्टम इसको समझाता हूं
मैं अभी मींस दिस पेलोड इज नॉट डाउनलोडेड
टू द टारगेट सिस्टम और इज नॉट
एग्जीक्यूटेड ऑन द डिस्क इट इज
एग्जीक्यूटेड इन मेमोरी एंड एज ए रिजल्ट
नो ट्रेसेस ऑफ द पेलोड आर लेफ्ट और फाउंड
ऑन द टारगेट सिस्टम व्हिच इज अगेन ग्रेट
इन अवॉइडिंग डिटेक्शन बेसिकली क्या होता
है कि जो मीटरप्रेटर पेलोड है वो एक
एडवांस एक मल्टीफंक्शन पेलोड है बेसिकली
वो क्या करता है कि वो आपके सिस्टम पे जो
टारगेट सिस्टम उस परे डिस्क के ऊपर
डाउनलोड होकर देन उसके बाद एग्जीक्यूट
होने की बजाव डायरेक्टली क्या कर उसकी
मेमोरी में रन करता है रम में रन करता है
जिसकी वजह से क्या होता है कि वहां पर कोई
भी ट्रेसेस नहीं मिलते कि यहां पर कोई
पेलोड एग्जीक्यूट हुआ है और जिससे क्या हो
उसके डिटेक्शन के चांसेस भी कम हो जाते
हैं इट कम्युनिकेट्स ओवर ए स्टेज सॉकेट
एंड प्रोवाइड एन अटैकर विद एन इंटरेक्ट
कमांड इंटरप्रेटर ऑन द टारगेट सिस्टम दैट
फैसिलिटेट द एग्जीक्यूशन सिस्टम कमांड्स
फाइल सिस्टम नेविगेशन की लॉगिंग एंड मच
मोर और इसके यह आपको क्या करता है एक
कनेक्शन एब्लिश करके बदले में एक मिटर
पिटर सेशन प्रोवाइड करता है जिसके थ्रू आप
क्या कर सकते हो कोई भी फाइल उसके अंदर
अपलोड कर सकते हो की लॉगिंग कर सकते हो
कुछ कमांड सन कर सकते हो या सेल एग्जिट
सेल एक्सेस कर सकते हो उस सिस्टम का एक्स
मतलब जो भी प्रिज के आपको एक्सेस मिला
होगा समझ में आया कि मेटर प्रेटर क्या
होता है क्योंकि आप सबसे ज्यादा यूज करते
भी हो जिसने यूज नहीं किया तो हम यूज
करेंगे और जिसने यूज किया होगा उसको पता
होगा तो मेटर प्रेटर की एक बेसिक
डिस्क्रिप्शन था मैंने आपको प्रोवाइड कर
दिया मेटर प्रेटर कभी भी डिस्क के ऊपर
डाउनलोड नहीं किया जाता और डायरेक्टली
क्या करता है आपके मेमोरी के अंदर रन करता
है जिसकी वजह से इसको डिटेक्ट करना
डिफिकल्ट
है नाउ अभी बात करते हैं मेटा स्प्ड
फ्रेमवर्क फाइल स्ट्रक्चर के बार फाइल
सिस्टम स्ट्रक्चर के बारे में द एमएसएफ
मॉड्यूस लोकेशंस द मेटा स्लेट फ्रेमवर्क
स्टोर द मॉड्यूस अंडर द फॉलोइंग
डायरेक्टरी ऑन द
[संगीत]
इसके सारे के सारे क्या है मॉड्यूस की
लिस्ट मिलेगी नाउ उसके बाद अगर यूजर
स्पेसिफाइड और कस्टम मॉड्यूस है आर
स्टोर्ड अंडर द फॉलोइंग डायरेक्टरी ऑन द
[संगीत]
ली दिखा देता हूं इसका कि यह चलते हैं अभी
हम अपनी मशीन के ऊपर
ना यह रहा तो गो टू
आवर पैरेट ओस नाउ य जूम हो जाएगी शायद
इसको मैं कर दूंगा जूम व्यू
और ओके नाउ गो टू योर फाइल सिस्टम एंड
उसके बाद मैं इसको कंपलीटली आपके स्क्रीन
के सामने शो कर देता हूं कंट्रोल प्लस
शिफ्ट कंट्रोल प्लस
प्लस यह रहा इसके अंदर आपको क्या जाना है
यूजर के अंदर यूजर यूजर के अंदर शेयर गो
टू योर शेयर डायरेक्टरी देन उसके बाद आपको
क्या करना है गो टू योर मेटा स्प्लिट
फ्रेमवर्क अ यह रहा यह रहा यह रहा यह रहा
इसको मैं जूम कर देता हूं कंट्रोल
प्लस यह रहा एम के अंदर चलते हैं मेटा
स्लेड फ्रेमवर्क मेटा स्लेड
फ्रेमवर्क देखिए एलम एओ प क
यह रहा मेटा स्लेट फ्रेमवर्क आपको दिखाई
दे रहा होगा यह रहा मैट स्लेट फ्रेमवर्क
इसके अंदर भी आपको देखने को मिलेगा
मॉडल्स यह रहा मॉडल्स अब यहां पर जो मैंने
आपको बताया था
देखिए यह रहा ऑक्ल मॉड्यूल इनकोडर्स इजन
एक्सप्लोइट नोब्स पेलोड्स पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन मॉड्यूल ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल के
अंदर देखिए मतलब काफी मतलब अच्छे तरीके से
इसको क्या किया गया है
अ सलाइज किया गया है मतलब अच्छे तरीके से
ऑर्गेनाइज किया गया है स सो दैट कि आप
उसको अच्छी तरीके से यूज कर पाओ जैसे कि
देखो एडमिन से रिलेटेड आपके ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल
ये हैं जैसे आप देखोगे क्रॉलर से रिलेटेड
स्कैनर से रिलेटेड और मैं बात कर एसक्यूएल
से रिलेटेड यह सारे क्या है इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग के फेज है जैसे कि मैं अब क्या
करता हूं स्कैनर प जाता हूं देन उसके बाद
मुझे एक काम करना है प्लस ये रहा इस तरीके
से का पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करनी है मुझे इसके
थ्रू तो मैं भी कर सकता हूं देखो ये रहा
आपका एसी के स्कैन एफटीपी बाउंस स्कैन सिन
स्कैन टीसीपी स्कैन एक्स मास स्कैन ये सार
इन मॉड्यूल का यूज करके क्या कर सकते हो
आप स्कैनिंग कर सकते हो देखिए
अब ओके इस तरीके से आप इनको कर सक यूज कर
सकते हो देन गो बैक हम बैक चलते हैं यह
आपका कौन सा था ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल अब इसके बाद
इनकोडर मॉड्यूल ये रहा आपका इनकोडर के
अंदर सीएमडी
पीएचपी 36 30 32 बिट और 64 बिट नाउ उसके
बाद एक्सप्लोइट मॉड्यूल के अंदर चलते हैं
देखिए ये एक्सप्लोइट मॉड्यूल के अंदर
अकॉर्डिंग टू योर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम आपको
एक्सप्लोइट प्रोवाइड किया गया जैसे आपका अ
ओपन बीएसडी फ्री बीएसडी ए
[संगीत]
पेलोड पेलोड सेक्शन के अंदर भी वही है
स्टेज पेलोड स्टेज सिंगल्स एडेप्टर्स यह
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आप क्या करने वाले हो
अपकमिंग क्लासेस में जैसे जैसे आप आगे
बढ़ो ग एमएसएफ कंसोल को भी यूज करोगे तो
यह था इसका फाइल स्ट्रक्चर ऑफ मेटा एलोट
फ्रेमवर्क ये र आपके सारे मॉड्यूल जो
मैंने आपको बताया था ऑक्सल इनकोडर इजन
एक्सप्लोइट नोप्स पोस्ट मॉड्यूल ठीक है तो
अ इसको मैं क्या करता हूं क्लोज कर देता
हूं नाउ गो बैक टू आवर स्लाइड्स एंडस
वन आवर स्लाइड नाउ एवरीवन गट
क्लियर हां अखिलेश जो भी हम एक्सप्लोइट
भेजते हैं तो एक्सप्लोइट के साथ हम पेलोड
अटैच करते हैं अब पेलोड डिपेंड करता है कि
पेलोड किस टाइप का है कि आपने मिटर पटर
पेलोड को यूज किया तो क्या होगा कि उसके
अंदर वलन बिलिटी है तो उस वनटी का फायदा
उठाएगा उसके बाद ऑटोमेटिक आप वहां पर
कनेक्शन एब्लिश करके आपको मीटर सेशन मीटर
प्रेटर सेशन प्रोवाइड कर देगा अदर वाइज
आपने ऐसा पेलोड किया भेजा है कि आप मीटर
प्रेटर सेशन को यूज नहीं करना चाहते लेकिन
आप क्या कर रहे हो अपने सिस्टम पे किसी
पोर्ट पर लिसन कर रहे हो रिवर्स कनेक्शन
के लिए लेकिन पेलोड किसी टाइप का है जैसे
नेट कट के थ्रू तो आप उस तरीके से क्या
करोगे जैसे ही वहां पर एग्जीक्यूट होगा और
सक्सेसफुली एग्जीक्यूट हो जाएगा वल्नरेबल
होगी तो क्या है उसका भी कनेक्शन आपको
अपने अटैकर के सिस्टम में देखने को मिलेगा
हा मयंक आपको एक्सेस कैसे मिलेगा उसके वो
आता आपका पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज का एक
पार्ट होता है जिसको हम बोलते हैं
परसिस्टेंट मतलब एक्सेस को कैसे मेंटेन
करोगे तो वो भी मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा अपकमिंग
क्लासेस में क् एक्सेस वनटी तो ठीक है व
वनटी पैच होगी तो या आपने आई एम
सॉरी अगर क्या हुआ कि वह सिस्टम रीस्टार्ट
हो गया तब भी वो कनेक्शन आपको कैसे मिलेगा
तो वह भी मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा अगर सिस्टम
लेबल होगा तो डोंट वरी आई विल टीच
यू चलो नेक्स्ट चलते हैं अब हम बात करते
हैं अभी कि एक और सवाल होगा आप सबके मन
में हाउ डू हाउ वी डू पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
विद मेटा स्लट फ्रेमवर्क मेटा स्प्लिट
फ्रेमवर्क के साथ पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
कैसे करेंगे या हाउ वी कैन इंटीग्रेट द
मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क विद आवर
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग या थर्ड क्वेश्चन
आपका हो सकता है कि हाउ वी कैन यूटिलाइज द
मेटा स्लेड फ्रेमवर्क फॉर पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग तो उसका सवाल ये है आपके सामने
देखो आपको पता है पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
लाइफ साइकल के बारे में या पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग फेज के बारे में सबसे पहले हम
क्या करते हैं इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग एनमने
करते हैं देन वलने बिलिटी स्कैनिंग करते
हैं एक्सप्लोइटेशन करते हैं पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन करते हैं उसके अंदर
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन करते हैं उसके बाद हम
क्या करते हैं मेंटेन पर्सिस एक्सेस करते
हैं अभी इनके अगेंस्ट मैं आपको कंपेयर
करूंगा मेटा स्लेड फ्रेमवर्क को कैसे
इंप्लीमेंट किया जाता है कौन से मॉड्यूल
को इनके अकॉर्डिंग यूज किया जाता है जैसे
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग और एन्यूमरेशन की बात
करता हूं तो हम यूज करते हैं ऑक्सल
मॉड्यूस ऑफ मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क अगर हम
वल्नरेबल स्कैनिंग की बात करने अगर मुझे
क्या करना है वनटी स्कैनिंग करनी है विद
दी हेल्प ऑफ मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क तो
उसके लिए अ मैं यूज करूंगा अपना ऑक्सल
मॉड्यूल प्लस में नेसस नेसस का जो रिजल्ट
है उस उसको भी हम क्या कर सकते हैं जो एन
मैप का भी रिजल्ट है उसको भी हम क्या कर
सकते हैं आपके मेटा स्लेट फ्रेमवर्क के
अंदर इंटीग्रेट कर सकते हैं वो भी आज ही
मैं सिखाऊंगा आपको कैसे इंटीग्रेट करते
हैं मैं ए मैप का सिखाऊंगा और नेसस की
कहानी आएगी तो नेसस के बारे में भी बता
दूंगा मैं जब हम बात करेंगे एक्सप्लोइटेशन
की तो एक्सप्लोइटेशन में हम मेटा स्प्लटर
वर्क का यूज करते हैं एक्सप्लोइट मॉड्यूल
या पेलोड मॉड्यूल का यूज करते हैं और
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन की बात करें तो हम
मिटर प्रेटर पेलोड का यूज करते हैं पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन के लिए के लिए मेटा स्प्लिट
फ्रेमवर्क का अब प्रिविलेज एस्ले की बात
आती है तो हम यूज करते हैं पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन मॉड्यूस और मेट रेटर
पेलोड्स का यूज करते हैं किसके अंदर मेटा
स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर अगर हम अपने
एक्सेस को मेंटेन करना है पर्सिल जो अभी
आपने पूछा था तो उसके लिए भी हम यूज करते
हैं पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन मॉड्यूल या
पर्सिस मॉड्यूल का यूज करते हैं जो आपके
मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर अवेलेबल
होते हैं तो दिस इज द कंपैरिजन ऑफ योर
पेनेट्रेशन टेस्टिंग लाइफ साइकल विद द
मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क इंटीग्रेशन तो इस
तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो कि आपके फेज
के अकॉर्डिंग मेट फ्लोट के मॉड्यूल आप यूज
कर सकते इन द योर पेटिंग टेस्टिंग जर्नी
या एथिकल हैकिंग जर्नी तो एवरीवन मे बी गट
क्लियर अब इनको कैसे यूज करना है और कुछ
खुद से रिसर्च करना होगा और कुछ मैं सिखा
दूंगा
आपको ओके
प्ली सभी चैट में रिप्लाई जरूर
कीजिए और यहां पर मुझे एक चीज बताइए सभी
के सभी सभी ने जो 4 जो रुपीज का हमने एक
छोटा सा आप लोगों के लिए
कुछ नोट्स के लिए स्टार्ट किया था कि सभी
ने जवाइन किया यहां पर अभी कोई भी बचा हुआ
है क्योंकि वहां पर आप लोगों के लिए बहुत
बड़ा सरप्राइज होने वाला है शायद आप लोगों
ने अगर ् चैनल पर जो
एक वीडियो देखा होगा शायद वन मिनट का जो
नितेश सर ने कुछ अपलोड किया था दिस इज अ
ट्रू आपको एक ग्रेट अप अपॉर्चुनिटी मैं
आपको प्रोवाइड करने जा रहा हूं जहां पर
आपको फ्री में
बट जिनको डेडिकेट मेरे साथ सीखना है
डेडिकेट कुछ करना है तो उनके लिए एक
गोल्डन अपॉर्चुनिटी मैं आपको प्रोवाइड
करता
हूं और उसमें मैं एक्सपेक्ट करता हूं कि
150 प्लस तो आने चाहिए मुझे उस पैसे से
कोई मतलब नहीं है बात है तुम्हारे इंटेंशन
की कि फ्री में भी अगर आप लोग नहीं जवाइन
कर सकते
लाइव क्लासेस को जो जस्ट मात्र मात्र
र किसी लाखों की चीज को अगर कोई र में
आपको डिलीवर कर रहा है तो सोचो
कि आपके लिए इससे बड़ा गोल्ड कहीं नहीं
मिलने वाला
उसी में टीसी ज्ञान उसी में ही आपको सारी
चीजें भी जल्दी मिलने वाली है आपको र आपके
लिए इतने हेल्पफुल होने वाले लाइफ में कि
आप सोच लो कि सोच भी नहीं सकते आप मतलब
इतने हेल्पफुल होने
वाले हाउ टू परचेस तो आपको क्या करना है
मैं आपको बता देता हूं गो टू डे
फोनिक्स अकेडमी देन गो टू डेफ अकेडमी आपको
यहां पर जाना है अकेडमी के अंदर टैग के
अंदर जाना है देन गो टू डीसी जीएसपी
प्रैक्टिकल देन यहां पर आपको ये लिखा हुआ
है डीसी सीएसपी प्रैक्टिकल सर्टिफिकेट
यहां पर सर्टिफिकेट मिलेंगे आपको
रिसोर्सेस मिलेंगे नोट्स मिलेंगे आपको
जस्ट ओनली ₹1 पे करना है यहां पर ही हम
आपको अपकमिंग क्लासेस में यहीं पर क्योंकि
जैसे ही हम क्या करने वाले हैं ना और
प्रैक्टिकली जाने वाले हैं बेसिकली अभी तक
थोरेट्स मैं इवोल्व कर रहा हूं देखिए ये
रहा अभी तक तो मैं थोरेट्स इवोल्व कर रहा
हूं सो दैट कि अभी मे और भी बहुत सारे
प्लांस है इस कोर्स के स्टार्टिंग से ही
मेरे प्लान थे कि कहां पर जाक आपको क्या
सरप्राइज देना है वो मेरा प्री प्लान है
कुछ नहीं कि मैं सडन प्लान नहीं कर रहा
मेरे सारे प्री प्लान रहते हैं कि आपको
कहां पर किस पॉइंट पर जाके सरप्राइज आपको
प्रोवाइड करना है तो वही है तो अभी तक
क्या
थोरेट्स ज्यादा रहेगा और वहां पर आपको
ज्यादा ही मजा आने वाला है जहां पर आप
लाइव लैब्स के साथ बेसिकली आप क्या करने
वाले हो लाइव तो चलेंगी
youtube4 गी बट वहां पर आप मेरे साथ
इंटरेक्ट कर सकते हो हम साथ में
कम्युनिकेट करते हुए और साथ में क्या
करेंगे लैब सॉल्व करेंगे इन्हीं कांसेप्ट
का यूज करते हुए वहां पर आपके कांसेप्ट भी
क्लियर होंगे क्योंकि आप वहां पर कुछ सवाल
होगा रिलेटेड टू कांसेप्ट आपके वहीं पर
क्लियर कर दिए जाएंगे ओके तो दिस इज अ
ग्रेट अपॉर्चुनिटी दि गोल्डन अपॉर्चुनिटी
जो आपको कहीं पर नहीं मिलने वाली और कोई
भी कभी नहीं प्रोवाइड करने
वाला प्रैक्टिकल सर्टिफिकेट आप 41 वाले
में अगर जवाइन कर लिया तो आफ्टर कंप्लीशन
ऑफ को को साब को सर्टिफिकेट इशू कर दिया
जाएगा या अमित यह उससे भी अच्छा है वह तो
अच्छा है हीय उसका भी कुछ लगता है अगर वह
आता है प्लस में ये कॉमिनेशन डालो आपको
लाइफ में बहुत कुछ सीखने को मिलने वाला है
और इससे भी एक एडवांस कोर्स है जो ऑलरेडी
चल भी रहा है जो 6 दिसंबर से स्टार्ट हुआ
और अगर अभी आप लोग उसके लिए रेडी नहीं हो
तो प्रिपेयर नहीं हो तो नेक्स्ट बैच के
लिए रेडी हो जाइए और उसके लिए आप अभी से
देखो मैंने आपके बहुत सारे पैसे सेव करवा
दिए आपके लाखों रुपए सेव करवा दे जस्ट अभी
फ्री डिलीवरी करके तो आप उसको अभी पेरेंट
से धीरे-धीरे एज ए एमआई इकट्ठा कीजिए और
उस कोर्स को डीसीएसपी जो कोर्स है उसको
नेक्स्ट बैच में ऑन प्रायोरिटी ज्यादा से
ज्यादा लोग उसको खरीद लीजिए ओके तो उसमें
फिर हम नितेश सर और मैं भी मैं भी आपके
साथ रहूंगा तो आप को और भी एडवांस चीजें
इसी का इससे और ज्यादा एडवांस इस वाले
कांसेप्ट नहीं करियर होंगे उसमें और
एडवांस कांसेप्ट रहेंगे तो आपको और ज्यादा
एडवांस रेड टीमिंग के ऊपर जाया जाएगा
बेसिकली ज्यादा से ज्यादा वहां पर और भी
कुछ ऐसे डीप कांसेप्ट होंगे जो शायद यहां
नहीं मैं करवा सकता मेरी एक लिमिटेशन है
यहां पर करवाने
की लाइफ टाइम एक्सेस है
जॉब के लिए सजेशन तब होगा तब आप पहले रेडी
होने चाहिए जॉब रेडी होने चाहिए तो यह जॉब
रेडी ही है आप बेसिकली आप जॉब रेडी होने
के लिए तो आपके पास स्किल होनी चाहिए ना
तो आप उसी टाइप से मैं आपको करवा रहा
हूं चलो अभी हम बात करते हैं एक और सवाल
कि हाउ टू इंस्टॉल एंड कन्फर द मेटा स्प्ड
फ्रेमवर्क यह भी हम सीखते हैं कि देखिए
इंस्टॉलेशन एंड कन्फेशन ऑफ मेटा स्प्लिट
फ्रेमवर्क सभी को पता है कि मेटा स्प्लिट
फ्रेमवर्क इज डिस्ट्रीब्यूटर बाय द रेपिड
7 जिस जो परचेज कर लिया गया था 2019 में
मे भी इट कैन बी डाउनलोडेड एंड इंस्टॉल एज
ए स्टैंड अलोन पैकेज ऑन बोथ wss4j
मतलब इस कोर्स में हम यूज करने वाले हैं
मेटा स्प्रेड फ्रेमवर्क जो कम्युनिटी
एडिशंस है व भी हम यूज करेंगे
वर्क को रन करने के लिए उसकी बहुत सारी
डिपेंडेंसीज होती हैं लेकिन जो एमएसएफ है
मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क है एंड इट्स
रिक्वायर्ड डिपेंडेंसी कम प्री पैक्ड विद
द काली लिनेक्स और इवन आपका पैरेट ओस
न थी डिपेंडेंसी को रिजॉल्व करते करते जो
घंटों का काम था वह आपको अभी कुछ नहीं
करना जस्ट आपको अपडेट करना उसको रन करना
है दिस इज द सिंपल प्रोसीजर्स ऑफ द मेटा
स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क उसको मैं अभी
प्रैक्टिकली दिखाऊंगा अभी एक चीज होती है
मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर मेटा
स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क डेटाबेस एमएसडीबी जिसको
हम बोलते हैं इज एन इंटीग्रल पार्ट ऑफ द
मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क एंड इज यूज टू कीप
ट्रैक ऑफ ऑल योर असेसमेंट स्कैन डाटा और
ऑल ऑफ योर डाटा दैट यू विल बी वर्किंग विद
और इंटरेक्ट ंग विद इन द मेटा स्प्लिट
फ्रेमवर्क विल बी स्टोर्ड इन द एमएसडीबी
बेसिकली क्या होता है कि मेटा जो स्प्लिट
फ्रेमवर्क है उसके अंदर आप जो भी काम करते
हो चाहे आप पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करते हो
एन्यूमरेशन करते हो या वनटी असेसमेंट करते
हो पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन करते हो
एक्सप्लोइटेशन करते हो या प्लीज एस्केलेशन
करते हो या कोई भी सेशन एस्टेब्लिश करते
हो वो सारे के सारे चीजें क्या होते हैं
बाय डिफॉल्ट भी आपके जो मेटा स्लोट के
अंदर सेव होते हैं ट्रैक किए जाते हैं रखे
जाते हैं सो दैट कि आपको वो चीज ें
बार-बार वो ना करनी पड़े तो वह सारी सारी
चीजें कहां पर स्टोर होती है आपकी मेटा
स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर मेटा स्प्लिट
फ्रेमवर्क डेटाबेस के अंदर जिसको हम बोलते
हैं एमएस एफडीबी ठीक है अभी जो एमएस
एफडीबी है जो मेटा स्लेट फ्रेमवर्क
डेटाबेस है वो यूज करता है आपके पोस्ट
ग्री
एसक्यूएल जो पोस्ट पोस्ट ग्री एसक्यूएल जो
आपका डेटाबेस है उसको यूज करता है अपने
प्राइमरी डेटाबेस सर्वर के रूप में इसलिए
वी विल आल्सो नीड टू इंश्योर दैट द पोस्ट
ग एसक्यूएल डेटाबेस सर्विस इज रनिंग एंड
कॉन्फ़िगर करेक्टली अगर हमें मेटा स्ड
फ्रेमवर्क को यूज़ करना है तो उसकी सबसे
पहली जो रिक्वायरमेंट है कि आपका जो पोस्ट
ग्री एसक्यूएल डेटाबेस है वह क्या होना
चाहिए आपका इनेबल और
कंफिट सही ढंग से अगर उसमें एरर होगी तो
आपका मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क में आपको एरर
देखने को मिलेगी द मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क
डाटा बेस आल्सो फैसिलिटेट द इंपोर्ट
इंपोर्टेशन एंड स्टोरेज ऑफ़ स्कैन
रिजल्ट्स फ्रॉम वेरियस थर्ड पार्ट टूल्स
लाइक ए मैप एंडस अब जैसे जो थर्ड पार्टी
टूल्स होते हैं अगर आप क्या चाहते हो उनका
जो रिजल्ट आया उसको आप क्या करना चाहते हो
इंपोर्ट करना चाहते हो या स्टोर करके रखना
चाहते हो मेटा स्लेड फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर वो
भी आप कर सकते हो विद दी हेल्प ऑफ मेटा
स्लेट फ्रेमवर्क डेटाबेस अब ये कैसे कर
सकते हैं मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा
देन उसके अब बात करते हैं हम इंस्टॉलेशन
प्रोसेस क्या होती है आपको सबसे पहले क्या
करना है अपनी जो काली
टेलेट फ्रेमवर्क के को लेटेस्ट वर्जन के
रूप में अपग्रेड करना है देन उसके बाद
आपको स्टार्ट और इनेबल करना है पोस्ट ग्री
एसक्यूएल डेटाबेस सर्विस को देन आपको क्या
करना है एमएसडीबी को इनिला इज करना है
उसके बाद एमएसएफ कंसोल को लॉन्च कर देना
है अभी प्रैक्टिकली हम इसको कैसे करेंगे
मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं प्रैक्टिकल
डेमोंस्ट्रेट तो यह हमारा प्रैक्टिकल
डेमोंस्ट्रेट फॉर एग्जांपल अभी मैं क्या
करता हूं मुझे आपको सबसे पहले क्या करना
है अपने रिपोजिटरी को अपडेट करना है कैसे
करोगे सुडो सब को स्क्रीन दिखाई दे रही है
एवरीवन जिस तरह की मैं आपको करवा रहा
हूं उसी ज्ञान जिस तरह की मैं आपको करवा
रहा हूं बस उसको फॉलो करते हिए उस पर
रिसर्च करते रहिए प्रैक्टिस करते हिए उस
रिलेटेड बेसिक फंडामेंटल्स आप करते रहिए
जहां चीज आपको लगती है कि ये टिपिकल पड़
रही है उससे रिलेटेड आप गल करो या एआई को
यूज करो उससे रिलेटेड जो कुछ मिलता है
पढ़ो बुक्स रिफरेंस की आप बात कर रहे हो
तो मैं आपको जल्दी बुक्स रिफरेंस आपको
प्रोवाइड कर दू आपको कौन-कौन सी बुक से
पढ़नी चाहिए डोंट वरी मैं जल्दी व भी उसके
ऊपर आपको रिकमेंडेशन दे दूंगा थोड़ा सा
टाइम दीजिए
मुझे ओके फ्रंट साइज इंक्रीज कर दू ओके हो
गया आपको क्या करना सुडो एटी
अपडेट सिंपली
यह आपकी रिपोजिटरी अपडेट हो जाएगी देन
उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है मेटा स्प्लिट
फ्रेमवर्क को क्या करना है अपग्रेड करना
है लेकिन मैं कैसे करूंगा अभी
सुडो
एटी
इंस्टॉल मेटा स्प्ले
फ्रेमवर्क अगर आपके में इंस्टॉल नहीं तो
आप ऐसे कर सकते हो हान वा यह रहा यह आपको
बता देगा कि जीरो अपग्रेडेड जीरो न्यूली
इंस्टॉल जीरो टू रिमूव जीथ नॉट अपग्रेडेड
ओके ठीक है तो बेसिकली आपका अप टू डेट ही
हैसे ये कौन सा वर्जन है आपका ऑलरेडी
न्यूस्ट वर्जन
6.4.3 देन उसके बाद मैंने आपको क्या बताया
था पोस्ट ग्रीस एसक्यूएल तो आपको क्या
करना है सुडो सुडो करना जरूरी है सुडो
उसके बाद सिस्टम एस वाई एस टीई एम सिस्टम
सीटीएल उसके बाद एक बार स्टार्ट स्टार्ट
उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है पोस्ट ग्री
एसक्यूएल ट एंटर ये सर्विस आपकी स्टार्ट
हो जाएगी देन उसके बाद आपको आपको स्टेटस
चेक करना
है यह देखिए यह क्या शो कर रहा है कि आपकी
जो सर्विस है क्या है आपकी एक्टिव है ओके
आपकी सर्विस क्या है एक्टिव है यह 47 मिनट
एगो दिखा रहा है मतलब काफी टाइम से एक्टिव
है तो देन उसके बाद आपको स्टेटस का पता चल
गया ना उसके बाद मैं क्यू प्रेस करोगे तो
यहां से एग्जिट हो जाएगा क्लियर कर देते
हैं अभी एक कमांड होती है एमएस एफडीबी
इससे जो इस डेटाबेस से इंटरेक्ट करने के
लिए
सुडो एमएसएफ डीबी हिट एंटर कीजिए ये इसकी
हेल्प फाइल है तो यू कैन यूज एन स्पेसिफिक
पोर्ट नंबर फॉर द पोस्ट ग्री एसक्यूएल
कनेक्शन सेटिंग द पीजी पोर्ट वेरिएबल इन द
करंट सेल जैसे इस तरीके से उसके बाद क्या
कर सकते हो आप यूज कर सकते हो इसके अंदर
कुछ होता है एमएसडीबी इट का मतलब होता है
स्टार्ट एंड इनिला द डेटाबेस अगर आप
फर्स्ट टाइम यूज कर रहे हो एमएसएफ कंसोल
को तो आपको को सबसे पहले क्या करना है
एमएस डीवी इनिला
इज कॉपी एंड आपको सिंपली सुडो और यह
कंट्रोल शिफ्ट ब यह करना है ओके डाटाबेस
ऑलरेडी स्टार्टेड डेटाबेस अपीस टू बी
ऑलरेडी कन्फर एंड स्किपिंग इनिला इजेशन
नाउ उसके बाद अगर आपको क्या करना है री
इनिला इज करना तो आपको ये क्या करेगा आपको
डिलीट एंड री इनिला इज मतलब क्या है कि जो
भी आपके अंदर जो डाटा सेव होगा डेटा बेस
के अंदर उसको डिलीट करके उसको री इनिला
करेगा अगर आप चाहते हो तो री इनिला इज
करना कई बार अगर इसमें एरर देखने को मि
मिती है तो उसके एमएसडीबी डिलीट अगर किसी
डेटाबेस डेटाबेस फाइल को डिलीट करना तो भी
डिलीट कर सकते हो स्टार्ट करने के लिए
स्टार्ट कर सकते हो स्टॉप करने स्टॉप कर
सकते स्टेटस जाने स्टेटस तो फॉर एग्जांपल
मुझे अभी चेक करना है
सुडो
एमएसएफ डीबी उसके बाद में स्टेटस एसटी एटी
यूएस स्टेटस देखिए यह क्या शो कर रहा है
ऑलरेडी आपका रनिंग है ओके लिसनिंग पोर्ट
है यह आपके शो कर रहा है नाउ आईपीवी फ के
लिए और यह रहा 5432 नाउ क्लियर
सी एल ई ए आर क्लियर ओके ना हो गया अभी
मुझे क्या करना है अभी एमएसएफ कंसोल को
स्टार्ट करना तो एमएसएफ कंसोल सिंपली आपको
क्या करना है हिट
एंटर एमएसएफ कंसोल और हिट एंटर इट विल टेक
टाइम अगर फर्स्ट टाइम काफी टाइम बात चला
रहे होगे या फर्स्ट टाइम
होगा इट विल टेक
टाइम हा पीडीएफ पडी नोट में कुछ टाइम के
लिए अवेलेबल नहीं था मैं सर के साथ
कांटेक्ट में नहीं था तो ट्स वई आई एम नॉट
एबल टू सेंड द पीडीएफ नोट तो आज के और कल
के बिफोर नेक्स्ट क्लास में भी आज ही मैं
अपलोड कर दूंगा मोस्ट प्रोबेबली या कल
आपको मिल
जाएंगे देखिए इट विल टेक टाम आपको शो कर
रहा है कि मेटा स्ट वर्जन 6.4 दे 2473
एक्सप्लोइट आर अवेलेबल 1275 लरी मॉड्यूल
393 पोस्ट मॉड्यूल एंड 1475 पेलोड्स 49
इनकोडर 13 नोप्स ना इवेज मॉडल्स आर
अवेलेबल अ इस तरीके का इंटरफेस आपको देखने
को मिलता है एमएसएफ कंसोल के अंदर अभी अब
अब मैं चाहूं तो यहां भी चेक कर सकता हूं
कि मेरा जो पोस्ट ग्रस एसक्यूएल की जो
सर्विस है वो एक्टिव है या नहीं है तो
कंफर्म करने के लिए मैं यूज करूंगा डीबी
उसके बाद अंडरस्कोर
स्टेटस स्टेटस हिट एंटर तो ये आपको बता
रहा है कनेक्टेड टू एएए कनेक्शन टाइप
पोस्ट एएल तो अभी मैं य इसी को यहीं पर
स्टॉप कर रहा हूं कंटिन्यू स्लाइड के साथ
करते अभी आपको बता दिया कि कैसे इसको
इंस्टॉल और कन्फर करना है तो आपको हमेशा
ध्यान रखना है कि एमएसएफ कंसोल को यूज
करने से पहले उसका जो पोस्ट ग्रस एसक्यूएल
जो डेटाबेस सर्विस है वह आपकी क्या होनी
चाहिए स्टार्ट होनी चाहिए अदर वाइज आपको
एरर देखने को मिलेगी तो यह हो गया एक तो
चीज मैं आपको जो बताना चाहता था फिर से हम
अपनी स्लाइड पर चलते
हैं नाउ अभी हम बात करते
हैं एमएसएफ कंसोल फंडामेंटल्स के बारे में
एमएसएफ कंसोल फंडामेंटल एमएसएफ कंसोल क्या
होता है देखो इ इट इज एन इजी टू यूज ऑल इन
वन इंटरफेस दैट प्रोवाइड यू विद एक्सेस टू
ऑल द फंक्शनल ऑफ द मेटा स्लेट फ्रेमवर्क
बेसिकली हम इसी के ऊपर हैंड्स ऑन करने
वाले हैं पूरे कोर्स के अंदर इसी को हम
यूज करने वाले हैं और इसी को ज्यादातर यूज
करते हैं एज ए ओपन सोर्स या एज ए
कम्युनिटी एडिशन जिसको हम बोलते हैं तो ये
क्या है इजी टू यूज ऑल इन वन इंटरफेस वो
सारे काम कर सकते हो इसके अंदर
मेटा स्लेड फ्रेमवर्क वाले ठीक है मींस
एवरीथिंग पर्टिनेंट टू द पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग कैन बी डन थ्रू द मेटा स्लेड
फ्रेमवर्क कंसोल मैं आपको एग्जांपल के साथ
समझा चुका हूं कि आप पूरी की पूरी
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग लाइफ साइकल को ऑटोम
ऑटोमेटिक इस एमएसएफ कंसोल के द्वारा कर
सकते हो नाउ अभी आपको फिर से एक सवाल होगा
कि व्हाट एगजैक्टली वी नीड टू नो टू बी
कंफर्टेबल विद द मेटा स्लोट फ्रेमवर्क
कंसोल अगर मुझे मेटा स्लोट फ्रेमवर्क
कंसोल के साथ कंफर्टेबल फील करना है या
मुझे करना है कि उसको यूज करना है तो मुझे
क्या-क्या पता होना चाहिए बेसिक लेवल पे
तो मैं आपको बता देता हूं कि हाउ टू सर्च
फॉर मॉड्यूस मॉड्यूस के लिए आप कैसे सर्च
कर सकते हो ये आपको पता होना चाहिए हाउ टू
सेलेक्ट मॉड्यूस मॉड्यूल को कैसे सेलेक्ट
करना है यह भी आपको आना चाहिए मेटा स्लोट
फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर हाउ टू कंफिल मॉड्यूस
ऑप्शंस एंड वेरिएबल जो इसके अंदर जो भी
ऑप्शंस होते हैं जो भी वेरिएबल होते हैं
मॉड्यूस के अंदर उसको आप कैसे कंफिल कर
सकते हो कैसे सेट कर सकते हो यह भी आपको
आना चाहिए हाउ टू सर्च फॉर पेलोड्स
पेलोड्स को आप कैसे सर्च कर सकते हो हाउ
टू मैनेज सेशन सेशन को कैसे मैनेज कर सकते
हो एमएसएफ कंसोल के अंदर या हाउ टू सेव
अवर कन्फेशन जो हमारी कन्फेशन फाइल्स है
उसको भी हम कैसे सेव कर सकते हैं तो यह
सारी की सारी चीजें आपको बेसिक लेवल पे
मेटा स्पर्ट यूज करते वक्त आनी चाहिए ओके
और यह सारी की सारी चीजें मैं आपको आज ही
सिखा दूंगा इसको आपको चिंता करने की जरूरत
नहीं है ओके नाउ उसके बाद हम बात करते हैं
कि एमएसएफ मॉड्यूल वेरिएबल के बारे में कि
ये यह क्या चीज होती है क्योंकि जो
मॉड्यूस होते हैं मॉड्यूस के अंदर आप कोड
तो लिखा हुआ है लेकिन अगर हम उनको यूज
करते हैं तो उसके अंदर कुछ प्री डिफाइंड
वेरिएबल होते हैं उनकी वैल्यू को हम क्या
करते हैं सेट करते हैं उसके बाद ही हम उ
उसको एक्सप्लोइट करते हैं या उसको यूज
करते हैं तो उन वैल्यू को हमें सेट करना
होता है जिनको हम वेरिएबल बोलते हैं तो ये
क्या होता है मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क
मॉड्यूल विल रिक्वायर इंफॉर्मेशन लाइक
टारगेट और होस्ट आईपी एड्रेस
एंड पोर्ट नंबर इन ऑर्डर टू इनिशिएटिव
और कनेक्शन यह तो एक कॉमन सेंस की बात है
अगर मुझे किसी भी चीज के साथ रिवर्स
कनेक्शन या कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश करना है या
एक्सप्लोइट एक्सप्लोइट करना है तो उसके
उसकी हमें क्या करनी पड़ेगी उसकी
इंफॉर्मेशन तो प्रोवाइड करनी पड़ उसका
आईपी एड्रेस उसका पोर्ट नंबर यह सारी चीज
कॉमन सेंस के बात हमें प्रोवाइड करनी
पड़ेगी और वो सारी की सारी चीजें क्या
आपके मेटा स्लेट के अंदर वेरिएबल में डील
की जाती है फॉर एग्जांपल इफ आई एम यूजिंग
ए विंडोज एक्सप्लोइट मॉड्यूल दैट इज
टारगेटिंग ए वर्जन ऑफ विंडोज एंड इज
एक्सप्लोइटिंग विनेबिलिटी ऑन ए टारगेट इज
एक्सप्लोइटिंग ए वलने बिलिटी ऑन ए टारगेट
तो देन इन ऑर्डर टू एक्सप्लोइट द टारगेट
वी रिक्वायर आईपी एड्रेस पोर्ट नंबर टू बी
कंफिट फॉर दिस एक्सप्लोइट मॉड्यूल टू रन
सक्सेसफुली एंड दिस इज वयर द मेटा स्पेड
फ्रेमवर्क मॉड्यूस वेरिएबल कम इन टू प्ले
तो बेसिकली क्या है कि मुझे अगर उस
वल्नरेबल को जो आपकी कौन सी बताई थी मैंने
कोई भी वनटी ट उस वनटी को एक्सप्लोइट करने
के लिए मुझे उसके अंदर आईपी एड्रेस सेट
करना पड़ेगा उसका पोर्ट नंबर सेट करना
पड़ेगा ताकि जो एक्सलरेट मॉड्यूल से व
अपना काम सही तरीके से कर पाए ओके और यह
सारी चीजें हम क्या करते हैं वेरिएबल के
अंदर क्या करते हैं डील करते हैं अभी कुछ
वेरिएबल आपको देखने को मिलते हैं हम
नॉर्मली देखने को मिलेंगे कि दीज ऑप्शंस
कैन बी कॉन्फिडो द यूज ऑफ मेटा स्प्ड
फ्रेमवर्क वेरिएबल इट अलाउ यू टू सेट बोथ
लोकल एंड ग्लोबल वेरिएबल एक और चीज होती
है आप लोकल और ग्लोबल वेरिएबल दोनों ही
सेट कर सकते हो मेटा फलेट फ्रेमवर्क के
अंदर लोकल वेरिएबल वही होते हैं कि जिस
टाइम आप यूज करें उसी टाइम काम करेंगे
ग्लोबल वेरिएबल क्या होते हैं एक बार आपने
ग्लोबल वेरिएबल सेट कर दि तो जैसे ही उसका
कोई भी एक्सप्लोइट मॉड्यूल यूज़ करोगे
पेलोड मॉड्यूल यूज़ करोगे तो जहां पर उसकी
रिक्वायरमेंट है ऑटोमेटिक उसकी वैल्यू फील
कर दी जाएगी बार-बार आपको फिल करने की
जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी अभी कुछ ये कॉमनस जो
वेरिएबल हैं ये आपको बार-बार देखने को
मिलेंगे बार-बार आपने यूज़ किए होंगे या
बार-बार यूज करते हो तो इनके बारे में
आपको बता देता हूं एल होस्ट दिस वेरिएबल
इज यूज्ड टू स्टोर द आईपी एड्रेस ऑफ द
अटैकर सिस्टम जो अटैकर सिस्टम्स है उसका
हम आईपी एड्रेस स्टोर करने के लिए इस
वेरिएबल का यूज करते हैं एल होस्ट एल
पोर्ट का हम कब यूज़ करते हैं दिस वेरिएबल
इज यूज्ड टू स्टोर द पोर्ट नंबर ऑफ द
अटैकर सिस्टम दैट विल बी यूज्ड टू रिसीव ए
रिवर्स कनेक्शन अगर मुझे क्या करना है कि
जो टारगेट सिस्टम उससे रिवर्स कनेक्शन
चाहिए तो यहां पर मैं क्या करता हूं पोर्ट
नंबर मेंशन करता हूं व भी अटैकर्स का तो
उसके लिए इस वेरिएबल को हम यूज़ करते हैं
आर होस्ट का हम यूज़ करते हैं दिस वेरिएबल
इज यूज्ड टू स्टोर द आईपी एड्रेस ऑफ द
टारगेट सिस्टम या सर्वर सर्वर जो टारगेट
सिस्टम है उसका अगर मुझे आईपी एड्रेस सेट
करना तो हम किसके अंदर सेट करते हैं आर
होस्ट के अंदर आर होस्ट्स भी होता है दिस
वेरिएबल इज यूज टू स्पेसिफाई द आईपी
एड्रेस ऑफ द मल्टीपल टारगेट सिस्टम और
नेटवर्क रेंजेस अगर मुझे क्या करना है कि
मल्टीपल टारगेट सिस्टम्स है या म रेंज है
टारगेट की अगर उनको उनका आईपी एड्रेस मुझे
क्या करना है सेट करना है तो हम आर होस्ट
के अंदर सेट करेंगे क्योंकि सेम
एक्सप्लोरेटिव टारगेट हैं और उनके अंदर
सेम टाइप की वल्नरेबल के चांसेस है तो हम
क्या कर सकते हैं आर होस्ट वेरिएबल का यूज
कर सकते हैं आर पोर्ट की बात करें तो दिस
वेरिएबल स्टोर द पोर्ट नंबर दैट वी आर
टारगेटिंग ऑन द टारगेट सिस्टम अगर मुझे
क्या टारगेट सिस्टम का क्योंकि पोर्ट तो
डेफिनेटली हमें मेंशन करना है कि इस पोर्ट
को हम एक्सप्लोइट करना चाहते हैं तो उस
पोर्ट का जो वैल्यू है उस पोर्ट का जो
नंबर उसको हम किसके कर किसके अंदर स्टोर
करते हैं आर पोर्ट वेरिएबल के अंदर तो यह
कुछ बेसिक वेरिएबल से आपको ज्यादातर सेट
और अनसेट करने पड़ते हैं और देन जो अदर जो
वेरिएबल होंगे तो हम साथ के साथ काम करते
करते सीख लेंगे नाउ इसका भी प्रैक्टिकल
डेमोंस्ट्रेट आपको दिखा देता हूं मैं कि
कैसे हम मॉडल को सर्च करेंगे कैसे मॉडल को
सेलेक्ट करते हैं कैसे कन्फर करते हैं
कैसे पेलोड को सर्च करते हैं कैसे सेशन को
मैनेज करते हैं कुछ और भी कुछ फंक्शन टी य
सारी चीज अभी हम प्रैक्टिकली देखते
हैं उमेश मैंने लिंकडन काफी दिन से ऑन
नहीं किया है ट्स
वई उमेश बताया ना मैं आपकी रिक्वेस्ट देख
लूंगा भाई यहां धमका क्यों रहे हो चैट में
देर ओनली अभी देखिए जस्ट कुछ टाइम के लिए
मेरे को रिस्पांस देने के लिए आ गए जस्ट
और अभी 38 पर आ गया गुड बहुत अच्छा
रिस्पांस आप लोगों
का ना चलो मैटलो फ्रेमवर्क मेरा काम कर
रहा है तो मुझे अगर अभी मुझे नहीं पता
ब्लाइली मैं एक ब क्लियर कर देता हूं नाउ
अभी मुझे नहीं पता कि मुझे इसको यूज कैसे
करना है नहीं पता आई डोंट नो कि मुझे इसको
यूज ही कैसे करना है तो उसके लिए मैं इसको
क्या करूंगा
देखिए नाउ तो यहां पर मैं यूज कर सकता हूं
एक तो क्वेश्चन मार्क यह आपका हेल्प मेनू
ओपन करेगा या आप हेल्प लिख सकते हो तो
यहां पर वो सारे जो भी कमांड्स आप यूज कर
सकते हो यहां पर लिस्ट आउट कर देगा देखिए
ये रहा हेल्प मेनू बैनर सीडी कलर कनेक्ट
डी बग एग्जिट फीचर गेट देखो गेट क्या होता
है गेट द वैल्यू ऑफ ए कांटेक्ट स्पेसिफिक
वेरिएबल गेट जी क्या होता है गेट द वैल्यू
ऑफ ग्लोबल वेरिएबल गेट रप हेल्प हिस्ट्री
लोड क्विट दे आर लॉट ऑफ ऑप्शन दैट यू कैन
यूज योर पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग जर्नी या यू
कैन यूज योरसेल्फ ओके ये खुद से आपको करने
हैं एकएक ऑप्शन के बारे में एक बार
एटलीस्ट एक बार पढ़ लीजिए आपको आईडिया हो
जाएगा कौन-कौन से ऑप्शंस यूज किए जाते हैं
ए मैं स्क्रीन को क्लियर कर देता हूं अभी
फॉर एग्जांपल मुझे क्या करना है कि अभी
मुझे वर्जन जानना है तो वर्जन करने के लिए
मैं यूज करूंगा इसका वर्जन एक देखो दिस इज
द फ्रेमवर्क
6.4.3 कंसोल 6.4.3 ओके देन उसके बाद अगर
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं सो ऑल एक कमांड होती
है सो ऑल तो यह जितने भी एक्सप्लोइट्स हैं
जितने भी मॉड्यूस है सबकी लिस्ट आपके
सामने शो कर देगा और काफी बड़ी लिस्ट है
यह देखिए बहुत बड़ी लिस्ट है देखो आप बहुत
बड़ी लिस्ट है मतलब जितने भी पोस्ट
एक्सप्लो मॉड्यूल थे पेलोड थे या ऑक्सल
मॉड्यूल सबको इसने लिस्ट आउट किया सबको
सबको एक साथ ठीक है अगर मुझे क्या करना
ओनली एकएक को ओनली एक्सप्लोइट मॉड्यूल को
करना है या ऑरी मॉड्यूल को करना है तो वो
भी मैं कर सकता हूं तो अभी मैं एक बार
स्क्रोल डाउन करते हम और देन ये स्क्रीन
को क्लियर
करते नाउ उसका हम यूज करेंगे सो ऑक्सल ए
यू एक्स आई एल आई ए आर वाई ऑक्ल मॉड्यूल
हीट एंटर ये देखिए ये ओनली न 174 ओनली जो
लरी मॉड्यूस है उनकी लिस्ट आपके स्क्रीन
के सामने इसने शो कर दी देखिए यह
देखिए तो अगर मुझे ओनली एक्सप्लोइट
मॉड्यूस के बारे में फाइंड आउट करना है वो
भी मैं कर सकता हूं कैसे शो एक्सप्लोइट्स
ई एक्स पी एल ओ आई टी एस एक्सप्लोइट तो
जितने भी एक्सट मॉड्यूल है 2473 तो उनकी
लिस्ट इसने आपके सामने शो कर दी जैसे ये
इसका नाम है डिस्क्रिप्शन है कब इसको इसके
अंदर लोड किया गया था उसके एक्सीलेंट
ग्रेट मैन यस यह बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
आपके सामने दी गई है अभी एक और चीज होती
है अगर श को हम कैसे यूज करने तो श हाइन
एच भी यूज कर सकते हो आपकी हेल्प फाइल एच
तो शो के साथ हम क्या-क्या यूज कर सकते
हैं तो यह आपको एक एरर क्रिएट की और यह
देखो ऑल इनकोडर्स नोप्स एक्सप्लोइट
पेलोड्स ऑक्सल पोस्ट प्लगइन इंफो ऑप्शंस
फेवरेट यह सारे इसकी चीजें इसके साथ आप
क्या कर सकते हो पैरामीटर को यूज कर सकते
हो आपके श कमांड के साथ नाउ अभी मुझे फॉर
एग्जांपल
किसी भी मॉड्यूस के बारे में सर्च करना है
तो मैं कैसे करूंगा वह करने के लिए मैं
क्या करता हूं सर्च एक सर्च कमांड होती है
देन उसके बाद नेम ऑफ द मॉड्यूस फॉर
एग्जांपल मुझे क्या करना है पोर्ट स्कैन
पोर्ट स्कैन मॉड्यूल को सर्च करना है तो
हिट एंटर देखिए यह रहे टोटल सेवन है ये
लिस्ट आउट कर दिया इसने देखो पोर्ट स्कैन
एफटीपी बाउंस पोर्ट स्कैनर देन एक्स मास
एसी के टीसीपी सीन फॉर एग्जांपल अगर मुझे
किसी भी मॉड्यूल को यूज करना है तो इसके
दो तरीके से मैं इसको यूज कर सकता हूं एक
तो जैसे कि मैं एसी के वाले को यूज करना
फॉर एग्जांपल तो एक तो तरीका मेरा क्या है
सिंपली इसको सेलेक्ट करना है कॉपी एंड यूज
यूज कमांड देन उसके बाद कंट्रोल शिफ्ट भी
पेस्ट कर दिया हिट एंटर कर दिया एक तो
तरीका यह है आप इस तरीके से यूज कर सकते
हो और यहां पर आपको क्या देखने को मिलता
है ऑगरी जो मॉड्यूल यूज कर रहा प्रॉपर
डिटेल के साथ ऑक्सल स्कैनर पोर्ट स्कैन
एसी के कंप्लीट डिटेल के साथ साथ ये आपको
शो करता है अभी मैं इसको क्या करता हूं
बैक कर देता हूं य बैक किया अभी फिर से ये
वाला मॉड्यूल है कि अभी मैं ये क्या करता
हूं
सर्च पोर्ट स्कैन है नाउ अभी मुझे क्या
करना है दूसरा तरीका क्या है मुझे सिन
वाले मॉड्यूल को यूज करना है तो मैं य
सिंपली क्या कर सकता हूं यूज उसके बाद
ओनली सिक्स इसका जो आईडी है इसका जो नंबर
है वो मेंशन कर दो ट एंटर तब भी ये
मॉड्यूल आपका यूज हो जाएगा एक कमांड होती
है कि इसके अंदर मुझे कौन-कौन से ऑप्शन
सेट करना मुझे यह देखना है कि कौन-कौन से
वेरिएबल या कौन-कौन से ऑप्शंस जरूरी है
मेरे लिए सेट करना तो वो कैसे करूंगा मैं
वो भी आपको दिखा देता हूं देखिए तो एक
कमांड होती है श ऑप्शंस
तो ये र यह सारे ऑप्शंस है जो आप इसके
अंदर सेट कर सकते हो देखो बैच साइज द नंबर
ऑफ होस्ट टू स्कैन पर सेट यस रिक्वायर्ड
है जिसको यस लिखा वो आपके लिए रिक्वायर्ड
आपको सेट करना ही है डिले जीरो बाय
डिफॉल्ट सेट है इंटरफेस नो जरूरी जरूरी
नहीं है अब जैसे भी कंसन क्या पोर्ट्स ठीक
है वन से 10000 तक ये स्कैन करेगा यस
ऑलरेडी सेट है पोर्ज टू स्कैन देन उसके
बाद आर होस्ट यहां पर कौन सा है आर होस्ट
आपका सेट नहीं है उसके बाद देखो यस द
टारगेट होस्ट देन उसके बाद क्या है
थ्रेड्स ये अब मुझे इस ऑप्शन को सेट करना
तो मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं फॉर एग्जांपल
मुझे इसको सेट करना है तो सेट उसके बाद आर
होस्ट देन उसके बाद स्पेस टारगेट का आईपी
192.168
0.14 फॉर एग्जांपल और हिट एंटर कर दिया
मैंने ये क्या कर दिया आपका सेट हो गया
फिर से क्रॉस चेक करना तो शो
ऑप्शन सो ऑप्शंस यह देखिए अभी मेरा आर
होस्ट चेंज हो गया देखो यहां पर पहले खाली
था अभी यह फिल हो गया जहां पर कौन सी
वैल्यू
192.168 इस तरीके से आप किसी भी वेरिएबल
की वैल्यू को सेट कर सकते हैं अभी मुझे
पोर्ट को सेट करना जैसे कि सेट
पोर्ट्स कैसे करूंगा मैं वन से चाहता हूं
1 1000 ओनली 1000 ही चाहता हू हिट एंटर
मैंने इसको सेट किया फिर से मैं 100 ऑप्शन
करता हूं ये देखिए यह देखिए यहां पर 100
ऑप्शन अभी इस वन से 1000 पोर्ट्स आपके
सामने शो हो रहे हैं अगर मुझे इस मॉड्यूल
को रन करना है जो ये मॉड्यूल है इसको मुझे
रन करना है ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल को कैसे करूंगा
दो तरीके या तो आप रन लिख सकते हो या
एक्सप्लोइट लिख फिर मैंने रन कर दिया
देखिए अभी इस मैंने रन कर दिया तो इसने
आपको शो कर दिया ऑक्सल फेल्ड रन टाइम एरर
यू डोंट हैव परमिशन टू परफॉर्म दिस कैप्चर
ऑन दिस डिवाइस सॉकेट ऑपरेशन नॉट परमिटेड
सोन सो कुछ एरर आया है क्योंकि ये मेरी
ब्लॉक भी कर रही है आपकी रिक्वेस्ट को
क्योंकि विंडोज फायरवॉल्स और अभी मैंने
अभी क्रॉस चेक करना पड़ेगा कि मेरी मशीन
ऑन भी है या नहीं
है बस आपको मैंने आपको दिखाया
है हां सेट लगाना कंपलसरी है
आप करके देखिए एक्सपेरिमेंट सारे मॉडल को
आप एक साथ यूज कर सकते हो या नहीं कर
सकते हे मशीन को चेक कर लेता हूं मैं
ओके अभी मैं क्या करता हूं इसको अभी स
ऑप्स करता
हूं इसके थ्रू भी हम यूज करेंगे आपका
नरेशन में हम इसको भी दबा के यूज करने
वाले डोंट वरी तो अभी मैं क्या करता हूं
सेट आर होस देन उसके बाद
192.168 2222 हिट एंटर उसके बाद मैं क्या
कर रहा हूं सेट जो पोर्ट्स
थे 10000 ही कर देता हूं यह रहा उसके बाद
मैं इसको क्या करता हूं
रन कुछ प्रॉब्लम है इसको हमें वो करना
पड़ेगा तो बाद में देखता हूं इसको हम रन
करेंगे तो इस तरीके आप क्या कर सकते हो
अभी इसको यूज कर सकते हो
कुछ कुछ टाइप रर है या कुछ बेसिकली मेरे
साइड से फायर बल का इशू है ओके या परमिशन
का इशू है यही बता रहा है कि ऑपरेशन नॉट
परमिटेड ओके तो क्योंकि ये नॉर्मल यूजर से
किया हुआ मैंने यूज इसको नो
इशू देन उसके बाद मैंने आपको बता दिया किस
तरीके से आप किसी भी पेलोड को सर्च कर
सकते हो या किसी भी एक्सप्लोइट को सर्च
यहां पर क्या कुछ भी हो सकता है जैसे मैं
सर्च करना चाहता हूं एस ई ए आर सी एच सर्च
करना चाहता हूं
एचटीटीपी तो देखिए इस तरीके से अभी जितने
भी एचटीटीपी के रिलेटेड देखो
6673 को जहां ज एटीटीपी मिला इसको इसने
क्या कर दिया आपके सामने शो कर दिया एक यह
तरीका है नॉट ए गुड अप्रोच तो आप क्या कर
सकते हो सर्च कमांड की हेल्प फाइल को देखो
सर्च जो कमांड है आन एच देखिए मैं इसके
साथ कौन-कौन से ऑप्शन यूज कर सकता हूं
देखिए दे लॉट ऑफ ऑप्शन यू कैन यूज इट जैसे
कि एडेप्टर ऑथर सीवी चेक डेट
अभी मैं यूज करने वाला आपके सामने जैसे कि
यह रहा टाइप मॉडल्स ऑफ स्पेसिफिक टाइप
एक्सप्लोइट पेलोड ऑरी इनकोडर इजन पोस्ट या
नो उसके अलावा जैसे कि यह रहा अभी मैं
सर्च करना चाहता हूं देखो कि मैं सर्च
करना चाहता हूं की
सर्च उसके बाद टाइप मैं टाइप यूज करना
चाहता हूं लरी ए यू एक्स आई
एल आई ए
ऑक्सल ऑक्सल स्पेलिंग गलत है मे
बी ए यू एक्स आई एल आई ए आर वाई
ऑक्ल ऑक्सल देन उसके बाद मैं क्या करना
चाहता हूं टाइप ऑक्सल है उसके बाद मैं
क्या करना चाहता हूं पोर्ट
स्कैन पोर्ट स्कैन देखिए
या मैं हां ऑक्ल पोर्ट स्कैन या मैं चाहता
हूं चलो एसएमबी करता हूं एसएमबी ये रहा इट
एंटर अभी ओनली जितने भी ऑक्ल मॉड्यूल है
रिलेटेड टू एसएमबी वो सारे के सारे आपके
क्या करेगा आपके स्क्रीन के सामने शो
करेगा तो आपने क्या किया अपने रिजल्ट को
नैरो डाउन कर लिया तो इस तरीके से आप इसको
भी यूज कर सकते हो सर्च कमांड की हेल्प
फाइल को जब देखोगे कौन-कौन से ऑप्शंस का
क्या मतलब वो भी मैं सर्च कर सकता हूं फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं चाहता हूं कि विंडोज प्
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हो मेरा प्लेटफॉर्म हो और
एक्सप्लो फाइंड आउट करना चाहता हूं अभी
2017 की सीवी के साथ य आपके पास सीवी आईडी
है तो मैं कैसे कर सकता
हूं सर्च उसके बाद सीवी उसके बाद
2019 सर्च करना चाहता हूं 2019 यह मैं
टाइप मेरा क्या
एक्सप्लोइट एक्सप्लोइट अब
प्लेटफॉर्म प्लेटफॉर्म मेरा कौन सा है
विंडोज देखो हिट
एंटर अभी जितने भी रिलेटेड टू र 2019 के
होंगे और रिलेटेड टू जितने भी एक्सप्लोइट
होंगे विंडोज ये सारे सारे आपके सामने शो
कर एक्सप्लोइट मल्टी स्कैन ये आर स तो
जितने भी एक्सप्लोइट देखिए कर्नल
एक्सप्लोइट तो ये सारी सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
आपके स्क्रीन के सामने शो कर देगा तो इस
तरीके से क्या कर सकते हो आप किसी भी
मॉड्यूस के बारे में सर्च कर सकते हो उसके
बाद उसको यूज कर सकते हो उसके अंदर
वेरिएबल को सेट कर सकते हो ये चीजें मैंने
आपको सिखा दी उसके अलावा एक और चीज होती
है मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं कि आप जब किसी
भी अ सिस्टम को एक्सप्लोइट करते हो तो
उसके बाद वहां से आपको एक सेशन मेंटेन कर
दिया जाता है और कई बार आप क्या चाहते हो
कि उसके अंदर फर्द इननेशन करना चाहते हो
तो सेशन को क्या करना हो टर्मिनेट करने की
बजाय बैकग्राउंड में रन करते हो तो वही
इंफॉर्मेशन देखने के लिए आप यूज करते हो
सेशन सेशंस अभी मेरे पास कोई भी एक्टिव
सेशन नहीं है तो इसलिए यहां पर कोई भी
इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को अदर वाइज जितने भी
एक्टिव सेशन होंगे टारगेट सिस्टम के साथ
यहां पर लिस्ट आउट आ जाएंगे और उनको यूज
करने का तरीका क्या है आपका सेशन उसके बाद
डॉट आई उसके बाद स्पेस आईडी आप यूज कर
सकते तो वहां पर उस सेशन पे आप कंटिन्यू
लगातार मतलब तुरंत शिफ्ट कर जाओगे और उसको
यूज कर पाओ फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने क्या किया
किसी भी टारगेट के साथ मीटरप्रेटर सेशन को
एस्टेब्लिश किया तो और उसके बाद कंट्रोल
जड कर दिया उसको बैकग्राउंड में रख दिया
और उसके बाद मैं इसको मेटा स्पले
फ्रेमवर्क को यूज कर रहा हूं तो क्या होगा
जैसे आप सेशन कमांड को यूज करोगे तो वहां
पर आपको एक्टिव सेशन देखने को मिलेगा कि
रो व एक्टिव सेशन और किस आईपी एड्रेस के
साथ वो सेक्शन सेशन मेंटेन किया गया है तो
वो इंफॉर्मेशन आपको सेशन के अंदर देखने को
मिलती है तो मैंने आपको सिखा दिया कैसे आप
इसको यूज कर लोगे अभी
एवरीवन समझ में आ गया ये सवालों का जवाब
मिल गया ना कि यह वाला जो मैं आपको बता
रहा था यह रहा कि हाउ टू सर्च फॉर मॉड्यूल
हाउ टू सेलेक्ट मॉड्यूस हाउ टू कंफिल
ऑप्शन और वेरिएबल पेलोड को कैसे सर्च करना
है इन्हीं तरीके से सेशन को कैसे मैनेज
करना कॉन्फिन को आप आगे सीख जाओगे यह सारी
चीज आप कर लोगे एवरीवन गट क्लियर
सुशांता तो मे बी यू कैन स्किप इट तो डोंट
रिक्वायर्ड अगर आप चाहो तो यह भी ओनली इस
पर भी कर लोगे तो कोई सुनी है ये भी एक
गुड कोर्स है और यह कर लोगे तो हैना फय भी
एवरीवन गट
क्लियर आप तो बोल रहे थे सर 5760 हो गए
हैं और अभी 32 आ गए
गुड आगे बढ़े
अ एक चीज होती है वर्क स्पेस मेटा स्पेड
कंसोल के अंदर देखो मेट स्पेड फ्रेमवर्क
वर्क स्पेस अलाउ यू टू कीप ट्रैक ऑफ ऑल
योर होस्ट स्कैन एंड एक्टिविटीज इट इज
एक्सट्रीमली यूजफुल व्हेन कंडक्टिंग
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग वर्क स्पेसेस अलाउ यू
टू सॉर्ट एंड ऑर्गेनाइज योर डाटा बेस्ड ऑन
द टारगेट और
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन बेसिकली मैं आपको बताता हूं
आगे चलते हैं ये तीन लाइन पढ़ते उसके बाद
मैं आपको इस लाइन को समझाता हूं ड्यूरिंग
पेनेट्रेशन टेस्टिंग यू विल बी परफॉर्मिंग
ए लॉट ऑफ एक्शंस फॉर एग्जांपल यू आर रनिंग
वेरियस मॉड्यूस स्कैनिंग ऑफ वेरियस
टारगेट्स एक्सप्लोइटिंग मल्टीपल टारगेट्स
एटस ऑल ऑफ दिस डाटा इज अगेन गोइंग टू बी
स्टोर्ड बाय द मेटा स्प्ड फ्रेमवर्क बट इट
विल बी स्टोर्ड बाय डिफॉल्ट विद इन द
डिफॉल्ट वर्क स्पेस ओके कि जब भी आप
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करते हो तो आप बहुत
सारे मॉड्यूस चाहे वोह आपके स्कैनिंग
मॉड्यूल हो एक्सप्लोइटेशन मॉड्यूल को यूज
करते हो और वोह सारा का सारा डाटा आपका
मेटा स्प्ड फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर स्टोर किया
जाता है व भी किसके अंदर वर्कस्पेस के
अंदर और कौन सी वर्कस्पेस के अंदर बाय
डिफॉल्ट अगर आप कोई भी वर्कस्पेस खुद से
क्रिएट नहीं करते तो बाय डिफॉल्ट वो
डिफॉल्ट वर्क स्पेस के अंदर सेव किया जाता
है और जो अभी क्या करता है उसके बाद क्या
है तो वही चीज मैं आपको समझाया इसलिए इट
इज एक्सट्रीमली यूजफुल व्हेन कंडक्टिंग
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग लेकिन जब वर्क है
इसको यूज करना यह काफी हेल्पफुल हो सकता
है जब आप पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करते खास कर
के जब आप क्या कर रहे हो मल्टीपल
ऑर्गेनाइज के साथ डील कर रहे हो मल्टीपल
ऑर्गेनाइज डील कर रहे हो आप अपना काम
ऑटोमेटिक कर रहे हो तो आप टारगेट और
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के बेस पर आप क्या कर सकते
हो कोई भी खुद की वर्क स्पेस क्रिएट कर
सकते हो उसको मैनेज कर सकते हो स्विच कर
सकते हो म सभी का डाटा अलग-अलग मेंटेन कर
सकते हो सो दैट कि एक वर्कस्पेस से दूसरी
वर्क स्पेस में आप क्या करते हो स्विच
करके और यह इंफॉर्मेशन शो कर सकते हो कि
मैंने असेसमेंट के दौरान या स्कैनिंग के
दौरान आपकी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन रिलेटेड यह डाटा
मैंने क्या किया है कैप्चर किया है सो दैट
की वो डाटा आपका मिक्स नहीं होगा अगर डाटा
मिक्स नहीं होगा तो कंफ्यूजन नहीं होगा और
क्लेरिटी रहेगी
आपके टारगेट्स को या ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस को कि
ओके य ये डाटा य ये सर्विसेस या ये चीजें
क्या है कि मेरे साइड से वीक है तो इस
तरीके से हम क्या कर सकते हैं वर्क स्पेस
को मैनेज और मेंटेन खुद से क्रिएट करते
हैं अभी प्रैक्टिकली भी आपको दिखा दूंगा
कि मैं मेटा स्प फम कंसोल के अंदर हम क्या
करते हैं वर्क स्पेस को कैसे में यूज करते
हैं दूसरा हम साथ के साथ प्रैक्टिकल
करेंगे कि जो एन मैप है एन मैप का जो भी
रिजल्ट है हम उसको कैसे इंपोर्ट करते हैं
किसके अंदर मेटा स्पेड फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर
तीसरी चीज मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा कि मेटा
स्प्लिट को कैसे रन करते हैं विद दी हेल्प
ऑफ एमएसएफ कंसोल यह दोनों चीजें मैं आपको
बता दूंगा चलो अभी प्रैक्टिकली चलते हैं
यह रहा इसको क्लियर करते एक
बार ना तो अभी हम देखते हैं कि देखो अभी
वर्क स्पेस चेक करता हूं वर्क स्पेस एक
कमांड होती है वर्क
स्पेस हाइन एच यह
देखिए हाइन ए का मतलब क्या है कि अगर आपको
कोई भी वर्क स्पेस ऐड करनी है उसको ऐड कर
सकते हो डी का मतलब अगर किसी भी वर्क
स्पेस को आपको डिलीट करना है वो भी कर
सकते हो सारी के सारी वर्क स्पेस को डिलीट
करना वो भी कर सकते हो एक साथ हान एल
लिस्ट करना चाहते हो वर्कस्पेस की वो भी
लिस्ट आउट कर सकते हो आप और हान आ रिनेम
भी कर सकते हो सर्च भी कर सकते हो या वर्ब
बसली भी वो कर सकते हो तो फॉर एग्जांपल
मैं डायरेक्टली वर्कस्पेस यूज करता हूं
वर्कस्पेस मैंने और हिट एंटर कर दिया है
तो अभी मैं किसके अंदर हूं डिफॉल्ट
वर्कस्पेस के अंदर हूं मैं किसके अंदर हूं
डिफॉल्ट वर्कस्पेस अब मुझे कोई भी वर्क
स्पेस क्रिएट करनी है तो मैं कैसे करूंगा
हाइन ए उसके बाद मैं टेस्ट डे फरोनिक्स
यह रहा हिट एंटर यह रहा सक्सेसफुली क्रिएट
कर दिया और अभी मैं देखूंगा जिसको मैंने
क्रिएट किया अभी मैं कौन से वर्क स्पेस
में वो भी देखता हूं देखो
वर्कस्पेस हिट एंटर अभी मैं क्या करता हूं
जो रेड है मतलब अब प्रेजेंटली हम उस वर्क
स्पेस के अंदर कौन सी डे फोनिक्स
वर्कस्पेस के अंदर हूं अगर मुझे डिफॉल्ट
वर्कस्पेस के अंदर क्या करना है शिफ्ट तो
मैं कैसे करूंगा वर्क स्पेस उसके बाद
डिफॉल्ट यह रहा हिट एंटर तो अभी मैं
डिफॉल्ट वर्क स्पेस के अंदर क्या कर दिया
शिफ्ट किया मैंने हिट एंटर देखिए अभी मैं
डिफॉल्ट के अंदर हूं फिर से अगर मुझे क्या
करना स्विच करना है टेस्ट वाला तो टेस्ट
के अंदर भी मैं स्विच कर सकता हूं तो बहुत
इजीली हम स्विच कर सकते हैं टेस्ट वर्क्स
यह रहा इसके अंदर स्विच अगर मुझे क्या
करना है चलो कोई नहीं अभी मुझे इसको डिलीट
ही करना कि मुझे इसकी जरूरत नहीं है
वर्कस्पेस हाइन डी कर देंगे इसको हम
इस तरीके हम क्या कर सकते हैं डिलीट भी कर
सकते हैं तो इस तरीके से आप क्या कर किसी
वर्क स्पेस को क्रिएट डिलीट और स्विच कर
सकते हो या मैनेज कर सकते हो डिलीट कर
दिया अभी क्या करते हैं हम वर्क स्पेस ड
एंटर करते हैं देखो ना अभी ओनली एक ही
वर्क स्पेस है कौन सी डिफॉल्ट वर्कस्पेस
है और जिसके अंदर हम है अभी इसमें हमने
कुछ काम नहीं किया तो हम देख सकते हैं
होस्ट करके देखें तो कुछ नहीं है यह रहा
होस्ट होस्ट करेंगे ये रहा अभी तक कोई भी
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है इसके
तो इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते वर्कस्पेस
को मैनेज कर सकते हो अभी मैं आपको सिखाता
हूं कि जो आपका एन मैप है जो आप एन मैप
यूज करते हो उसका जो रिजल्ट है आप उसको
कैसे क्या कर सकते हो इंपोर्ट कर सकते हो
किसके अंदर मेटा स्प्ड फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर
वो कैसे करेंगे मैं आपको दिखाता हूं जस्ट
सेक मुझे क्रॉस चेक करने दिया सिस्टम
रनिंग है
या एनीथिंग
डाटाबेस ऑन कीजिए
तो आपके पास लैपटॉप नहीं है तो आप नहीं
सीख सकते फिर
आप छोड़ दीजिए फिर आप ट्रेनिंग को मैं सच
बोलूंगा मैं आपको गुमराह नहीं करूंगा मुझे
इससे कोई बेनिफिट नहीं है बट अगर आपके पास
य जो चीज आप सीखने के लिए उससे रिलेटेड
आपके पास चीजें नहीं है
[संगीत]
तो यू कांट डू एनीथिंग ब्रो चलो अभी हम
क्या करते हैं इसको मिनिमाइज करते हैं नाउ
एक और टर्मिनल ओपन करते हैं अभी मैं एन
मैप प क्या करता हूं
कंट्रोल
चलो सबको क्लियर दिखाई दे रहा है एवरीवन
चलो
एन मैप किया मैंने फॉर एपल मैं टारगेट को
चेक कर लेता हूं मैं टारगेट अभी पिंग
192.168 22 यस पिंग हो आर तो मेरा टारगेट
अभी लाइव है ओके अभी मैं क्या करता हूं ए
मैप किया मैंने और हान पीएन पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग किया मैंने पिंग स्कैन को स्टॉप
करके साथ के साथ मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन कर रहा हूं साथ के
साथ मैंने क्या किया ओस डिटेक्शन
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डिटेक्शन किया
देन उसके बाद टारगेट आईपी
19216801
222 ओके यह सारी चीजें मैं परफॉर्म कर रहा
हूं अपने टारगेट के ऊपर ट एंटर कर दिया
मैंने अभी आप देखोगे तो अभी जस्ट यह
इंफॉर्मेशन देख रहा हूं इस इंफॉर्मेशन
कैसे सेव
करके और अपने एन मैप के अंदर इंपोर्ट कर
सकते वो आपको दिखाऊंगा लेकिन पहले आपको
देखिए कि आप जस्ट एन मैप के रिजल्ट को
इतना ही मत कीजिए कि ओनली पोर्ट स्कैनिंग
किया ना आपके पास सर्विस वर्जन है ना ही
ओएस फिंगर प्रिंटिंग आपके पास या ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम डिटेक्शन है ना और ज्यादा
इंफॉर्मेशन है तो इस इंफॉर्मेशन को आप एप
के अंदर सॉरी उस इंफॉर्मेशन को अगर आप मेड
स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर इंपोर्ट भी
करोगे तो आपके लिए यूजलेस है क्योंकि मेटा
स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क क्या करेगा कुछ नहीं तो
इसलिए ट्राई करो पहले एमफ से एक डिटेल एक
कंप्रिहेंसिव रिपोर्ट या कंप्रिहेंसिव
रिजल्ट निकालो उसके बाद उसको एक फाइल मेकर
सेव करो और बेसिकली जो मेटा स्पेट
फ्रेमवर्क है उस परे जो फाइल है वो
एक्सएमएल फाइल ही स्टोर की जाती है जो
रिजल्ट है वो आपको एक्सएमएल फॉर्मेट में
ही क्या करना है स्टोर करके इंपोर्ट करना
है और अदर फॉर्मेट को स्पोर्ट नहीं करता
आपका मेटा स्प्ड
फ्रेमवर्क इट विल टेक टाइम मे बी हाउ मच
टाइम इट विल टेक आई डोंट
नो 95 हो गया
चलो सेशन में बोर हो रहे हो क्या या सबको
आता ही है तो नॉट रिक्वायर्ड
ओनली आंसर भी है कि स्टूडेंट देता बाकी
कोई देता भी नहीं मैं पूछने पर वेरी बैड
यार नहीं सुधरोगे आप लोग
मुझे ही खराब होना पड़ेगा आप लोगों के
लिए यह देखिए यह सारी सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
मेरे पास अवेलेबल अभी मैं इसको क्या करता
हूं मतलब काफी यूजफुल इंफॉर्मेशन वर्जन की
इंफॉर्मेशन है और ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की भी
इंफॉर्मेशन है विंडोज 88.1 है या विंडो
सर्वर 2008 है तो देखिए अभी मैं इसको क्या
करता हूं य कमांड है सिंपली हाइन
ओ हान ओ कैपिटल एक्स होता है एक्स का मतलब
क्या होता है एक्सल फम फम में अपने आउटपुट
को क्या करना सेव करना है और फाइल का नाम
क्या है फ एपल मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
विंडोज उसके बाद सर्वर विंडोज सर्वर इतना
किया और हिट एंटर कर दिया अभी यह सारे का
सारा जो आउटपुट है आपके एक्सल फाइल
फॉर्मेट में स्टोर कर देगा एन मैप विंडो
सर्वर नाम की जो फाइल है और कहां पर व
फाइल मेरी होम डायरेक्टरी ऑफ रोट
या मुझे एक चीज छोटी सी चीज समझ में नहीं
आती मैं आपको स्टेप बाय स्टेप बाय पढ़ा
रहा हूं और आप सर्फ एक छोटी सी चीज को
सीखने के स पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट पर मुझे वो
करनी है बलड फोर्सिंग करनी है कैसे करूंगा
तो मैं एक चीज बताइए मक क्या मैं आपको
सारे कांसेप्ट को छोड़ के सारे एक रोड मैप
को छोड़ के सिर्फ पहले यही चीज सिखाऊं और
आपका काम हो जाए बस फिर आप क्लास छोड़कर
चले जाओगे बस बाकी के लिए कुछ माइन नहीं
रखता वो चीज वही चीज सिखाऊ जो आपको चाहिए
अभी बताइए मुझे एक बार आप जवाब
दीजिए हम सी सीक्वेंस बाय सीक्वेंस हर चीज
को सीख रहे हैं ना बट फोर्सिंग भी करेंगे
डायरेक्टरी अटैक भी करेंगे और हम पासवर्ड
भी फाइंड आउट करेंगे वर्डलिस्ट का भी यूज
करेंगे हर चीज करेंगे बट हर हर चीज का एक
समय है ना तो हर चीज अभी मैं कैसे बता दूं
आपको सडन एक एक घंटे की सीजन में आपको 150
हावर का कोर्स पढ़ा
दू तो मैं दिमाग में सवाल आया था लेकिन
देखो ना कि दिमाग में सवाल आया था टॉपिक
क्या चल रहा है और आप पूछ क्या रहे हो समझ
रहे
हो कि कोर्स एंड पर होता और तब ये सवाल
पूछ रहे होते तो एक सवाल वैलिड है अब
कोर्स के स्टार्टिंग पॉइंट पे जहां पर
स्टेप बाय स्टेप जा रहे हैं जहां तक अभी
तक हमने ऐसी चीजों पर कुछ फोकस भी नहीं
किया है और आप वहां पर यह सवाल पूछ रहे हो
तो आप सोच कि आपका सवाल की टाइमिंग गलत है
सवाल गलत नहीं सवाल की टाइमिंग गलत
है चलो अभी हम क्या करते हैं एलस करते हैं
अभी क्या विंडो सर्वर नाम से एक फाइल है
नो इशू अभी हम क्या करेंगे इसको इंपोर्ट
करेंगे अभी पीडब्ल्यूडी करता हूं मैं तो
मेरा क्या है होम r78
उसकी होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर है तो अभी
मुझे क्या करना है इंपोर्ट करना है इसके
रिजल्ट को किसके अंदर मेट फ्रेमवर्क के
अंदर तो अभी मैं क्या करता हूं एमएसएफ
कंसोल अब मैं दूसरे टर्मिनल पर रन कर लेता
हूं चलो ओपन टर्मिनल एक और
नाउ कंट्रोल
शिफ्ट दिस वन ओके अब ये आपका पैनल है अभी
मैं इसको क्या करता हूं चलो अभी इसको भी
मैं रूट यूजर से चला रूट यूजर की वज से
जड़ नहीं है एमएसएफ
कंसोल देन हिट एंटर कर दिया
मैंने थोड़ा मुझ पर ट्रस्ट कीजिए कि मैं
आपको जो भी सिखा रहा हूं मैं एक प्रोफेशनल
हूं पहली बात देखिए आपको नहीं पता होगा तो
मैं जो जिस तरीके से आपको सिखा रहा हूं यह
आपको मैं पहले बताया था हमने अनाउंसमेंट
किया था कि यह कोर्स ईजी पीटी लेवल का है
उससे भी ऊपर है मतलब सी इसी के सा ने कुछ
नहीं है तो उससे ऊपर का यह कोर्स है तो
सोच लो कि जीजी पीटी आप इससे क्रैक कर
सकते हो मान के चलो कि आप उसको क्रैक कर
सकते हो और कुछ बेसिक फंडामेंटल लेवल्स ऑफ
ओससीपी के हैं तो सोचो इस कोर्स का लेवल
क्या होगा कितना ड्यूरेशन का हो सकता है
और क्या-क्या इसका कंटेंट आपको पढ़ाया
जाएगा खुद से सोचिए जो दिमाग पर जोर लगाए
तो आपको पता चल जाएगा इस लेवल का कोर्स है
ये और हर चीज एक बारीकी से एक वेरी डिटेल
एक प्रेसा इज मैनर में जा रही है आपकी और
आपको ऐसी ऐसी चीजें सिखाई जाएंगी जो आप
आपने भले ही आपको सीच कहीं से किया हो
लेकिन आपको नहीं बताया गया होगा इतना
डिटेल्स इस तरीके से आपको नहीं बताया गया
होगा ठीक है तो वह सारी चीजें आपको सिखाई
जाएंगी डोंट
वरी ना अभी हम क्या करेंगे इंपोर्ट करेंगे
बेसिकली क्या होता है कि जो आपका ये है ना
जो मेड स्लेट कंसोल है इस पर आप नक् कमांड
यूज कर सकते हो फॉर एग्जांपल मैं इफ
कॉफिया तो वो भी इस पर काम करेगा देखो इफ
कॉन्फिडो कर रहा है तो आप इसकी लिनक्स
कमांड अंदर फायर कर सकते हो ओके क्लियर कर
देता हूं तो अभी मुझे क्या करना है
इंपोर्ट करना है इंपोर्ट करने के लिए मैं
क्या करूंगा सबसे पहले एक वर्क स्पेस
क्रिएट करूंगा
वर्कस्पेस आईन ए क्रिएट किया मैंने
एक
विंडोज और उसका नाम क्या है विंडोज एनम
ओके विंडोज एनम हिट एंटर किया और मैं वर्क
स्पेस करता हूं अब हम काम वर्क स्पेस में
करेंगे ओके वर्क स्पेस की स्पेलिंग गलत है
मेरी
इसके अंदर हू अभी मैं क्या करूंगा इसके
अंदर हो गया अभी अभी मैं क्या कमांड होती
है डीबी अंडर स्कोर
इंपोर्ट डीबी इंपोर्ट देन उसके बाद फुल
पाथ अभी मैं क्या करूंगा फुल पाथ क्या
मेरा कौन सा होम होम देन उसके बाद मेरा
फुल पाथ क्या है आर
78 ना r7 उसके बाद मेरा क्या है विंडोज
क्या नाम था मेरा विंडोज सर्वर
विंडोज
अंडरस्कोर सर्वर ओके विंडोज सर्वर और ट
एंटर कर देता हूं यह रहा देखिए इंपोर्टिन
एन मैप एक्सल डाटा पार्सिंग विद द सोन सो
इंपोर्टिन होस्ट
192.16 अभी य इसके अंदर इंपोर्ट कर लिया
मैंने अभी मैं कमांड फायर करता हूं होस्ट
देखिए एओ एसटी एस होस्ट अभी आपको बता रहा
देखो होस्ट की इंफॉर्मेशन आपके सामने शो
कर रहा
ना एक अरेंज वे में देखो
समझ पा रहे हो कि मतलब आपके लिए कितना
यूजफुल है
ये अभी मैं इसको क्या करता हूं फिर से
होस्ट देखो आईपी एड्रेस क्या आपके होस्ट
का
192.168 जो उसके अंदर इंफॉर्मेशन वही
फाइंड आउट कर मैक एक अरेंज वे में
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम य विंडो डिटेक्ट कर पाए
लेकिन उसम अलग था उसम जो इंफॉर्मेशन
प्रोवाइड की है परपज क्लाइंट व्ट एवर
होस्ट किया उसके अलावा फॉर एग्जांपल मैं
क्या करता हूं
सर्विसेस सर्विसेस की फॉर्म में जो भी
सर्विसेस उसके ऊपर थी देखो एक टेबल की
फॉर्म पट 21 टीसीपी ठीक है प्रोटोकॉल उसके
बाद एफटीपी एसएस एचटीटीपी देन उसके बाद
स्टेटस का ओपन है उसकी इंफॉर्मेशन जो फरदर
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइल के अंदर एक एक्सएमएल
फॉर्मेट में थी वो सारी इसने अरेंज वे में
अपने फाइल के अंदर सेव किया उसके बाद आप
मल्टीपल कमांड को यूज करके फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हो सारी इंफॉर्मेशन इस तरीके से क्या
कर सकते हो आप इंपोर्ट कर सकते हो किसका
नेसस का जो आउटपुट है या एन मैप का आउटपुट
है थर्ड पार्टी टूल्स है उसके आउटपुट का
क्या कर सकते हो इंटीग्रेट कर सकते हो
इसके अंदर या इंपोर्ट कर सकते हो एवरीवन
गट क्लियर सबको समझ में आया कैसे कर सकते
हैं
एवरीवन सबको समझ में आया
ओके सभी रिप्लाई कीजिए किया करो आपको ताकि
मुझे भी आईडिया मिल जाता है किसी को रिपीट
करना हो तो प्लीज बता दिया करो मेरे
को चलो अभी हम बात करते हैं फॉर एग्जांपल
अभी मुझे ए एन मैप रन करना विद द हेल्प ऑफ
मेटा स्लेट फम वर्क मतलब मेटा फ्रेमवर्क
में अगर मुझे एन मैप को रन करना तो मैं
कैसे कर सकता हूं तो सबसे पहले मैं क्या
करता हूं अभी एक बार जो वर्क स्पेस है
वर्कस्पेस एस पीएसी वर्कस्पेस फन ए एक और
वर्कस्पेस मैं क्रिएट कर लेता हूं जिसका
नाम क्या है ए मैप वर्कस्पेस नाम मैंने रख
दिया अभी मैं इसके अंदर ही
हूं स्पेस ओके ए मैप के अंदर हूं अब मुझे
अगर ए मैप को यूज करना है किसके अंदर मेटा
फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर तो कैसे कर सकता हूं
डीबी अंडर ए मैप डीबी अंड ए मैप उसके बाद
हाइन पी ए ओनली हान पीए यूज कर रहा हूं
देन उसके बाद यह रहा t4 यूज कर रहा हूं
देन उसके बाद टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस 192
168.0 222 ऐसे यूज़ कर सकते
हो और हिट एंटर देखिए तो जिस तरीके से
आपका एन मैप रन कर रहा था आउटसाइड विदाउट
मैट स्फ फ्रेमवर्क एज इट इज इसके अंदर भी
आप एन मैप रन करवा सकते हो इस तरीके से
डीब ए मैप उसके बाद जो भी ऑप्शंस आपको
कंफिल करने हैं करने हैं उसके टारगेट आईपी
एड्रेस ये उसी तरीके से काम करेगा जैसे
आपके अभी लिनक्स टर्मिनल के अंदर काम कर
रहा था बिल्कुल एगजैक्टली आप उसी तरीके से
काम करेगा और इसका जो रिजल्ट है अभी आपको
फायदा क्या हुआ उससे पहले आपने क्या किया
था इसका जो आउटपुट था आपको सेव करवाना
पड़ा था किसी एक्सएमएल फॉर्मेट में और देन
उसको इंपोर्ट करना पड़ा था अभी क्या है कि
आपके पास वो हेडेक नहीं है आपको इंपोर्ट
करने की जरूरत नहीं होगी सिंपली जो भी
आउटपुट आएगा वो ऑटोमेटिक इस जो वर्क स्पेस
है इसके अंदर सेव हो जाएगा इंपोर्ट हो
जाएगा और डायरेक्टली मैं चेक कर सकता हूं
फिर मतलब ये बेनिफिट इसके अंदर ए मैप यूज
करने का एवरीवन गट क्लियर इट विल टेक टाइम
अब इसको चेक कर लेते हैं अभी 48.0 हुआ है
हो जाएगा और
भी यस एन मैप नाम देना मैंडेटरी है भाई वो
कैसे फ उसको पता चलेगा कि मैं कौन सी
कमांड रन कर रहा हूं आप जिसको यूज कर रहे
हो तो बताना पड़ेगा ना
सबको मैट स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क यूज करना आ
गया
अभी सभी
को इसके बाद थोड़ा सा पा मिनट की थ्योरी
और बच ग जो मैं आपको थोड़ा सा इंपोर्टेंट
इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करूंगा इसके बारे में
देन उसके बाद हम नेक्स्ट क्लास में एंटर
करने वाले हैं एन्यूमरेशन के अंदर देखिए
अभी बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन इसने कुछ उसने
किया अब मैं क्या करता हूं होस्ट देखिए
होस्ट टटर देखिए 192.168 0222 देन उसके
बाद मैं
सर्विसेस सर्विसेस यह देखिए अभी इसने कुछ
फाइंड आउट नहीं किया और ओके अभी इसने
ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट नहीं की जो
इंफॉर्मेशन इसने फाइंड आउट की वो आपके
सामने शो कर इग्नोर स्टेट फिल्टर टीसीपी
पोर्ट शो कर दिया नो रिस्पांस मतलब अभी
कुछ भी इंफो मिल फिल्टर्ड मतलब यहां पर
फायर वल एक्टिवेट हो गई मेरा पीसी अभी
फायरवॉल एक्टिवेट होग अचानक से स्लीप मोड
में जाता तो फायर वल एक्टिवेट होके
रिस्पांस देना बंद कर देती है मेरे सर्वर
वाली तो इस तरीके से जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन
इसने जो भी मिली इसने अपनी वर्क स्पेस के
अंदर सेव कर ली तो इस तरीके से आप क्या कर
सकते हो मेटा स्पेट के अंदर थर्ड पार्टी
टूल्स के रिजल्ट को इंपोर्ट कर सकते हो
इसके अंदर क्या कर सकते हो एन मैप को रन
कर सकते हो वर्कस्पेस कैसे क्रिएट कर सकते
हो सेशन को कैसे मैनेज कर सकते हो मॉड्यूल
को कैसे फाइंड आउट कर स कैसे यूज करना
उसके ऑप्शन को कैसे सेट करना ये सारी
चीजें आपको मैं सिखा चुका हूं उसके बाद जो
भी फर्द चीजें होंगी एमेशन में जैसे
एफटीपी एमेशन करेंगे नेट बायस एमेशन
करेंगे एसएमबी एमेशन करेंगे या एसएसएस एनम
मेशन करेंगे माय स्क एमेशन व सारे
एन्यूमरेशन हम दोनों तरीके से सीखेंगे
मैनुअल भी और ऑटोमेटिक विद द हेल्प ऑफ
मेटा स्ट फ्रेमवर्क की ल् से भी दोनों
तरीके से हम सीखने वाले अपकमिंग क्लासेस
में तो इस तरी इसकी आपको चिंता करने की
जरूरत नहीं है कि सर क्या सिखाएंगे क्या
नहीं सिखाएंगे सर सब कुछ सिखाने वाले हैं
ओके
सबको समझ में आ रहा
है पेनेट्रेशन टेस्टिंग का पेड बैच कब
क्या आएगा देखि कितना अच्छा सवाल है जो एक
फ्री बैच चल रहा है जो हाई ए डेकोरेटेड एक
बैच है आप उसको पढ़ नहीं रहे और आप पेड
बैच कौन सा आएगा आपको एक काम कीजिए फील द
स्पार्क अगर आपको पेड ट्रेनिंग चाहिए तो
वन टू वन ट्रेनिंग आई विल प्रोवाइड यू तो
आई विल कॉस्ट यू न
लाख गिव मी न लाख रुपी और बिगनर टू एडवांस
आई
विल कवर यू सैटरडे संडे आपकी क्लासेस
लूंगा
मैं वन टू वन ट्रेनिंग प्रोवाइड करूंगा आर
यू रेडी
दए मुझे और नेक्स्ट फोर टू सिक्स मंथ में
आपकी ट्रेनिंग कंप्लीट कर
दूंगा बताइए फील द स्पार्क आपके सवाल का
जवाब दिया मैंने
आपको नो आंसर
गुड मैं मजाक कर रहा हूं और आप मजाक नहीं
कर
रहे आपको पेड ट्रेनिंग चाहिए पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग की और यह क्या चल रहा है आई डोंट
नो अभी यह भी तो पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग ही
चल रही है
ना चलो एक छोटी सी इंफॉर्मेशन है ऑक्सल
मॉड्यूल के बारे में उसके बाद हम सेशन को
एंड कर देंगे इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन है और
नेक्स्ट मैं आपको चलो स्लाइड दिखा देता
हूं यह देखो यह रहा नेक्स्ट नेट बायस नमरे
आपका रहेगा चलो अभी आपको इंफो कर दिया
मैंने नेट बायस एमेशन के बारे में स्टार्ट
करेंगे मतलब कंपलीटली नमरे फेज करेंगे देन
उसके बाद हम जिसकी बात कर रहे थे आपके 41
पेज लाइव जो बोल रहे हैं ना कि हम क्या
करेंगे कि आई विल डिसाइड या उसके कुछ और
सेशन के बाद नमरे या स्कैनिंग नमरे और
वनटी स्कैनिंग के बाद मैं क्या करूंगा आई
एम प्लानिंग की जिस जिसने एनरोल किया है
₹1 जिसमें नोट्स वाले एनरोल किया है वहां
पर आपको सर्टिफिकेट मिलेगा प्लस में आपको
वहां पर मैं ग मट लिंक प्रोवाइड करने की
कोशिश करूंगा अभी तक जो प्लानिंग है मेरी
उसको एग्जीक्यूट कैसे करना है आई एम प्लान
कर रहा हूं और वी आर सक्सेसफुली तो देन जो
भी 500 स्टूडेंट्स होंगे वे लाइव जवाइन
करके वहां से
सीख सकते हैं बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ
कॉस्ट चलो ऑरी मॉड्यूल के बार बारे में
बात करते हैं ऑक्ल मॉड्यूल आर यूज टू
परफॉर्म फंक्शन लाइक स्कैनिंग नेटवर्क
डिस्कवरी फजिंग इट इज यूज फॉर एक्टिविटी
दैट डज नॉट इवोक द एक्सप्लोइटेशन ऑफ वलने
बिलिटी एंड अनदर फैक्टर दैट एन ऑक्सल
मॉड्यूल कैन नॉट पेयर विद पलट देखिए जो
ऑक्ल मॉड्यूल है उसको हम समझ सकते हैं कि
जो इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग करते हैं और नमरे कर करते हैं वह
सारे काम हम क्या कर सकते हैं ऑक्सल
मॉड्यूल की हेल्प से कर सकते हैं जैसे
स्कैनिंग होगी होस्ट डिस्कवरी होगी या
फजिंग होगी डायरेक्टरी अटैक्स हो गए लो
लेवल के थोड़े ब्रूट फोर्सिंग होगी वो कर
सकते हैं ऊपर से क्या है कि ये वनटी फा से
एक्सप्लोइट करने से पहले वाला फेज है और
थर्ड फैक्टर क्या है कि इसके साथ कोई भी
पेलोड पेयर नहीं किया जाता क्योंकि
एक्सप्लोइट के साथ पेलोड पेयर किया जाता
है लेकिन इसके साथ कोई भी पेलोड पेयर नहीं
किया जाता वी कैन यूज ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल टू
परफॉर्म बोथ टीसीपी यूडीपी पोर्ट स्कैनिंग
एज वेल एज नमरे इंफॉर्मेशन लाइक सर्वे
इंफॉर्मेशन फ्रॉम सर्विसेस लाइक एफटीपी
एसएसएस एचटीटीपी अगर मुझे इनसे इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग करनी है इन सर्विसेस से जो किसका
पार्ट होता है एन्यूमरेशन का पार्ट वह भी
हम ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल की हेल्प से कर सकते हैं
ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल कैन बी यूज्ड ड्यूरिंग द
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग फेज ऑफ पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग एज वेल एज द पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन
फेज एक तो जो एनमने गैदरिंग फेज है जो
नॉर्मल एमेशन गैदरिंग फेज उसमें यूज किया
जाता है दूसरा आप क्या कर सकते हो पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज में इसको यूज कर सकते
हो इन टर्म्स ऑफ इनिशियल पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग स्टेज दैट इवॉल्व इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग द ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल विल वर्क वेरी
सिमिलर टू एन मैप अभी जो इनिशियल स्टेज की
बात करता हूं तो व बिल्कुल एन मैप की तरह
ही काम करता है लेकिन जब हम पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज की बात करते हो
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग के अंदर वहां पर यह
मेन रोल प्ले करता है वहां पर काफी यूजफुल
है आपके लिए अभी आपका एक सवाल हो सकता है
मन में सर इफ वी ऑलरेडी परफॉर्म पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग विद एनम एंड वी कैन इंपोर्ट द एन
मैप रिजल्ट इन टू मेटा स्ड फ्रेमवर्क देन
व्हाई डू वी नीड यूज लरी मॉड्यूल जब सर
मैं एन मैप का यूज कर ही सकता हूं एन मैप
से मैंने सब कुछ फाइंड आउट कर लिया तो
मुझे ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल की रिक्वायरमेंट क्यों
है
ओके
तो फॉर एग्जांपल देखिए
अभी यह मेरा क्या है एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन का
नेटवर्क है यह अटैकर्स है अटैक और यह क्या
है कि जो एक्सटर्नली एक्सेस किसको कर सकता
हूं मैं इस वेब सर्वर को एक्सेस कर सकता
हूं एक्सटर्नली मैं इस वेब सर्वर को
एक्सेस कर सकता हूं इसका मेरे पास आईपी
एड्रेस है इसके अंदर वल्नरेबल है तो अटैकर
ने क्या किया सक्सेसफुली वनबिल को
एक्सप्लोइट किया और इसका एक्सेस गेन कर
लिया यहां पर क्या कर लिया एक्सेस गेन कर
लिया मतलब रिवर्स सेल किया कैसे किया उसने
मतलब यहां पर एक्सेस गेन कर लिया कैसे ना
कैसे करके अभी वहां पर एक जस्ट एक सिंपल
सा स्कैन करता है और यह फाइंड आउट करता है
उसे पता लगा था क ओके जो ये वेब सर्वर है
यह इंटरनल नेटवर्क से कनेक्टेड है मतलब और
भी जो बहुत सारे पीसीज है या कुछ सर्वर्स
हैं या कुछ स्विचस हैं मतलब कुछ इंटरनल
नेटवर्क्स हैं इससे कनेक्टेड है मतलब ये
कने इसका कनेक्शन किससे है इंटरनल नेटवर्क
से ओके ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के इंटरनल नेटवर्क से
इसका कनेक्शन है अभी जब इसका इंटरनल
नेटवर्क से कनेक्शन देखिए अभी एक्सटर्नली
तो मैं इस नेटवर्क को जो इंटरनल नेटवर्क
था इसको मैं एक्सेस तो नहीं कर सकता बाहर
से क्योंकि इसका कोई भी एक्सेस नहीं है
इसकी इंफॉर्मेशन मेरे पास नहीं है लेकिन
इसको मैं एक्सेस कर सकता था तो अब जब
मैंने इसको एक्सेस किया और इसको
एक्सप्लोइट करके इस पर मैंने टेक ओवर कर
लिया तो मैं क्या कर सकता हूं इसके थ्रू
इसके थ्रू जो एक्सटर्नल जो अवेलेबल था
नेटवर्क अवेलेबल था जिसको एक्सटर्नली मैं
एक्सेस कर सकता इंटरनेट के थ्रू उसके थ्रू
मैं क्या करूंगा जो इंटरनल नेटवर्क है इस
कंपनी का इसको एक्सेस करने की कोशिश
करूंगा इसको एक्सेस करूंगा इसके अंदर वल
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करूंगा अभी जब यह
सिनेरियो आ गया यहां पर कि आपने इसको
एक्सेस कर लिया और मीटर पिटर सेशन आपने ले
लिया पेलोड के थ्रू तो मेरे को एक चीज
बताइए यहां पर सबसे ज्यादा अब मुझे यहां
पर क्या करना है एन्यूमरेशन करना है
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करनी है इस केस में इस
फेज में आपका ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल है जो मेटा
स्लेड फ्रेमवर्क का इज वेरी वेरी वेरी
हेल्पफुल कैसे क्योंकि देखो यहां ए मैप की
बाइनरी तो हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा या तो
मुझे अगर यहां पर ए मैप तो यूज कर नहीं
सकता अगर मुझे यहां पर ए मैप को यूज करना
है तो क्या करना पड़ेगा मुझे इसके ऊपर ए
मैप की एग्जीक्यूटेबल या बाइनरी फाइल को
क्या करना पड़ेगा ट्रांसफर करना पड़ेगा
देन ओनली ही मैं इसको क्या कर सकता हूं
इसके ऊपर एन मैप परफॉर्म कर सकता हूं रन
कर सकता हूं तो अब जब मुझे एक चीज बताइए
एजिस्टिफाई
[संगीत]
कंजूमिंग प्लस में चैलेंजिंग प्रोसीजर है
इसके ऊपर एन मैप की बाइनरी को इंपोर्ट
करके रन करवाना रदर देन कि आपके पास
ऑलरेडी ऑरी मॉड्यूल है उसका यूज करके इस
सिस्टम के अंदर एनम मेशन परफॉर्म करोगे
फर्द सर्विसेस को फाइंड आउट करोगे और फर्द
उस परे एक्सप्लोइटेशन ट्राई करोगे पिवेट
करोगे फिर तो इसीलिए जो आपका मेटा स्लेट
का ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल है पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन
क्योंकि एक्सप्लोइटेशन बा होती है पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन उसके भी अपनी आठ फेजस होते
हैं जो मैं आपको बताऊंगा तो पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन में आपके नरेशन में ऑरी
मॉड्यूल वेरी वेरी हेल्पफुल ट इज वाई की
री मॉड्यूल आपके लिए इंपोर्टेंट है इसीलिए
हमें री मॉड्यूल के बारे में पता होना
चाहिए ओके तो एवरीवन गट क्लियर
अंडरस्टैंड सबको समझ में आ
गया हा मोहम्मद उस पर सर्टिफिकेट पर लिखा
होगा डीसी जेएसपी प्रैक्टिकल
तो अगली दो मिनट आप लोगों के लिए हैं आप
लोगों का कोई भी सवाल है रिलेटेड टू द
टुडे क्लास तो आप मुझसे पूछ सकते हो डाउट
सेशन इज ओपन फॉर ऑल उसके बाद हम सेशन को
एंड करेंगे और नेक्स्ट सेशन आपका मे बी
मंडे होगा इवनिंग सेम टाइमिंग आपका मंडे
99 चांसेस परसेंट चांसेस आपके क्या है
आपका सेशन मंडे होगा और मंडे को आप रेडी
रहिए मंडे को और भी एक्साइटिंग चीजें करने
वाले आपको बता देता हूं नेट बायस
एन्यूमरेशन प्लस में एसएमबी नरेशन करेंगे
सर्विस मैसेज ब्लॉक और नेट बायोस दोनों के
बारे में पहले इंट्रोडक्शन लेंगे य कैसे
काम करते हैं क्या चीजें होती है उसके बाद
इनके ऊपर हम क्या करेंगे एन्यूमरेशन
परफॉर्म करेंगे वेरी वेरी वेरी इंपोर्टेंट
टॉपिक्स जब अपकमिंग क्लासेस में तो प्लीज
डोंट मिस द
क्लास ओके तो प्लीज बताइए स्टिल एनी वन
हैव एनी डाउट्स यू कैन आस्क मी
नाउ यस मोहम्मद
एपीटीपी ओल्डेस्ट जो वर्जन थे जो पहले
नक्स थे उनमें क्या है
एपीटीजी लेकिन अभी क्या है एपीटीसी काम चल
जाता है
गग बाउटी की वीडियो नित सर लेकर आएंगे
जल्दी तो किसी को कोई डाउट
है एनी वन हैव एनी डाउट्स
पूछिए रिलेटेड कांसेप्ट अब बग बाउंट की
सीरीज में नितेश सर लेकर आते हैं वही
चलाते हैं कब आएगी
तो वही बता सकते हैं हां पूछिए एक्सल आर ए
क्या डाउट आपका
यह कौन सा तरीका भा वीडियो कब एंड
करोगे जो मैं पूछ रहा हूं उसका रिप्लाई
कीजिए
ना और तुम्हें नहीं देखना तो यू कैन गो इट
किसी को कोई डाउट नहीं है प्लीज
क्यों लैंग्वेज बदलने में क्या प्रॉब्लम
होगी मतलब क्या हो गया कि उधर से रिप्लाई
मिल रहा है तो लैंग्वेज बदल लो
य के कुछ वायलेशन है इसलिए मैं उसको तोड़
नहीं रही व क्या हां मैं समझ गया
आप केरला की लैंग्वेज बोल रहे हो आई नो
वेरी वेल डोंट टीच
मी बट वही बता रहा मैं आपको कि कुछ वायलो
तोड़ना नहीं जाता ना मैं तोड़ने की कोशिश
करूंगा क् दे आर लॉट ऑफ सिंसियर
स्टूडेंट्स अदर वाइज आपकी बातों का जवाब
मेरे पास अच्छे से होता है स्पैमर्स के
लिए
एक्सलर
आट आई एम आल्सो नाउ इन
केरला च प्लेस आई विल नॉट टेल यू डोंट वरी
ओके तो मुझे केरला और यह अदर लैंग्वेजेस
जो साउथ लैंग्वेजेस के बारे में मुझे सबके
बारे में थोड़ा थोड़ा पता है ओके
मैट पलेट की लास्ट क्लास थ टीसी ज्ञान
इसके बाद नहीं करेंगे
ओके नो एक्सलर आट
नो यू कांट
गेस तोके मैं सेशन को एंड करता हूं और
सेशन को रखते हैं बाय बाय टेक केयर
एंड थैंक यू और सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन
जल्दी मिलते हैं डे आफ्टर
टुमारो ओके थैंक यू बाय बाय टेक केयर